Willkommen und willkommen und auf Wiedersehen.
Du siehst gut aus, Tim.
Ich sehe gut aus?
Wo? Das wäre eine gute Frage.
Auf dem Bild.
Auf welchem Bild?
Im Skype.
Ach echt? Was hab ich denn da für ein Bild?
Das war eigentlich nur ein...
Ach so, mein Tim-Standard-Bild, ja, das ist schon uralt, da sah ich noch gut aus.
Das war eigentlich nur ein Hinweis darauf, dass du immer noch in Toronto bist?
Ja, ich bin immer noch in Toronto, mittlerweile hier schon seit vier Wochen. Man gewöhnt sich langsam an die Stadt. Und es gibt auch viel Gutes zu berichten hier aus Kanada, kann ich euch sagen.
Was erzählst du?
Also Kanada ist ja... Ich war ja noch nie hier vor diesem Projekt. Das Projekt ist, die meisten Hörer werden es wissen, aber ich sag's vielleicht trotzdem nochmal, wir sind hier in Kanada und machen unsere dritte Blinken-Lights-Installation nach langer, langer Pause. Und das ist jetzt halt auch schon fast gelaufen. Jetzt zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme steht uns noch eine Nacht bevor, eine Samstagnacht hier in der City, wo man mal gucken muss, wie viel Publikum das dann noch anzieht, weil jetzt ist hier so quasi Weihnachten, denn am Montag ist Thanksgiving, der Erntedank, den wir ja jetzt nicht besonders feiern in Deutschland. Das ist hier ein ganz großes Ding und alle zieht es halt zum Truthahn am Montag und von daher treten hier entsprechende Heimreisewellen an und von daher wird das wahrscheinlich ein recht ruhiges Wochenende werden. Aber Kanada an sich, also zumindest kann ich ja, ich kann hier nur für Toronto sprechen. Toronto ist eine absurd freundliche Stadt. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also ich habe hier so viele Leute getroffen, die einfach total nett sind und darüber hinaus auch einfach nie jemanden getroffen, der nicht mindestens irgendeine Grundnettigkeit hat. Also so mit der Berliner, der Berliner Unfreundlichkeit.
Als Berliner also eher ungewohnt quasi.
Ja, das totale Gegenteil. Und es ist auch nicht so eine aufgesetzte Freundlichkeit, weißt du, dass hier jetzt alle nur so tun.
Also nicht die afrikanische Freundlichkeit?
Genau, sondern die sind so. Also hier ist einfach ein extrem cooles Miteinander am Staat. Und das ist ja auch eine extrem multikulturelle Stadt. 60% aller Kanadier sind mittlerweile asiatischer Herkunft. Auch so eine Zahl, die mir vorher so nicht bewusst war.
60%?
Jaja, ein Großteil der Kanadier, genau. Aber du findest halt hier auch irgendwie alles, schwarze, inner, weiße, Pipapo, durch die Bank eigentlich, die ganze Welt. Wo ist denn Toronto? Toronto ist eigentlich so von der Einwohnerzahl her vergleichbar mit Berlin. Es streckt sich natürlich ein bisschen, weil das hier natürlich viel flacher bebaut ist, und generell wird hier mit Platz ja auch anders umgegangen. Macht allerdings in der City nicht so den Eindruck, weil das natürlich so eine typische nordamerikanische Stadtstruktur ist. Das heißt, erstmal ist so ganz viel Suburbs, und dann wird es so ein bisschen dichter, und dann hast du natürlich so deine Wohngegenden. Die strecken sich ziemlich aus, und in der Mitte hast du dann eben so diese Kulminanz mit den großen Bürotürmen, so diese typische Skyline mit dem CN Tower ja auch. Hier ist vor kurzem auch das größte Gebäude der Welt.
Ach, CN Tower ist das Ding. Ich hab hier gerade so ein Foto von Toronto offen. Da sieht man auch die City Hall. Das ist doch relativ groß, oder? Also nicht so groß wie die ganzen Hochhäuser drumherum, aber schon groß.
Ist kein kleines Gebäude. Im Vergleich zu den Gebäuden drumherum wirkt es dann schon deutlich kleiner. Aber ist 25, 27 Std. hoch, also wirklich nicht klein. Und es ist das Wahrzeichen der Stadt. Man findet so eine stilisierte Form der City Hall ist als Logo. Prankt das hier auf allem öffentlichen gut, von der Mülltonne bis zu Geschäftspapieren.
Wie ist es denn jetzt gelaufen?
Wie ist denn das Logo? So wie das Stereoskop-Bildchen oder?
Ne, das Logo ist der Blick von vorne, d.h. du siehst so diese beiden Türme von vorne, der eine ein bisschen höher als der andere, aber eben nur so ein umrandetes Logo, nur so Liniengrafik und deswegen haben wir ja bewusst bei Stereoskop, wir haben uns zwar auch auf die City Hall bezogen, aber wir haben halt den Blick von oben genommen. Stereoskop ist sozusagen die Türme von oben mit diesem UFO da in der Mitte, wo das Parlament drin ist.
Ah, da ist das Parlament drin, ich dachte, das wäre so eine Parkanlage quasi oder so was in der Richtung, noch dazwischen den Gebäuden. Ich habe da nie so Fotos richtig von gesehen.
Eine Parkanlage, wenn du auf das Haus schaust, hast du links den Turm, rechts den Turm und in der Mitte ist so ein UFO, so ein rundes UFO da drin. Und das siehst du beim Simulator auch ganz gut. Und da ist halt das Parlament der Stadt drin. Da tagt der Bürgermeister und da wird halt so über die Geschicke der Stadt Toronto entschieden.
Und du bist jetzt dieses Hochhaus einige Male runtergerannt, nehme ich an, in den letzten Wochen?
Ja, wir kennen hier glaube ich jetzt jede Ecke.
Besser als der Bürgermeister.
Aller Techniketagen, Zulieferzonen, Ausdichtsplattformen, Netzwerkräume, also ich glaube es gibt wenig Leute, die hier so viel Überblick haben, wie wir jetzt.
Wie ist denn beim letzten Mal, klang es ja noch so ein bisschen u-oh und so, als ob es noch ganz schöne Probleme gibt. Hat denn alles geklappt noch zum Ende hin oder war es problematisch?
Ja, es war problematisch und es hat alles geklappt. Letztes Mal, als wir unseren Podcast aufgenommen haben, hatten wir hier einfach mit unserer neuen Wireless-Technik, würde ich hier gerne mal was erzählen können, doch arge Probleme. Die sind dann allerdings in einer wahnwitzigen Hack-Session, in so einer 24-Stunden-Dauer-Hack-Aktion weitgehend entfernt worden. Und in der darauffolgenden Woche, so bis zum Launch, letzten Samstag, lief es dann doch ziemlich gut. Es gibt jetzt nur noch so minimale, ab und zu mal kleine Aussetzer von einzelnen Pixeln. Da gibt es sicherlich noch den einen oder anderen Bug, den wir jetzt auch nicht mehr finden werden, weil die Arbeit ist jetzt im Wesentlichen eingestellt. Aber im Großen und Ganzen hat es halt funktioniert, und das ist schon ziemlich beeindruckend, weil wir haben ja die ganze Technik komplett neu entwickelt, neu erfunden sozusagen, und wir hatten vorher eigentlich keine wirkliche Möglichkeit, das in dem Scale zu testen.
Und du klangst von letztem Mal schon gerade zu panisch, muss man ja mal sagen, ein bisschen. Ja, das war schon eher so...
Das war aber auch nach der Sendung.
Stimmt, nach der Sendung.
Panisch würde ich nicht sagen, aber es war schon so, dass wir schon so über alle Optionen nachdenken mussten. Es war einfach nicht so richtig.
Was ist die Option? Heimlich das Land verlassen?
Ja, so was in der Richtung. Aber so ist das nun mal. Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich ohne Optimismus war. Es war bloß einfach ein Moment der totalen Anspannung und Konzentration. Man musste halt einfach wirklich genau dran arbeiten. Wir haben halt Fehleranalyse betrieben. Es gab so viele Fehler auf einmal, oder zumindest wirkte es wie viele Fehler auf einmal, die teilweise im Zusammenhang und teilweise nicht im Zusammenhang irgendwie erkennbar waren.
Erzähl doch mal ein bisschen was für Technik, bevor wir jetzt auf die Fehler einlegen.
Ich würde ganz kurz mal noch sagen, dass die Leute, zumindest die, die ein iPhone haben, sich ja mal das Stereoskop-Programm runterladen können, dann kennen sie parallel dazu schon auch noch live, wenn sie es, weiß nicht wann sie den Stream hören, aber die Installationen sozusagen sehen, damit sie es sich vielleicht besser vorstellen können.
Genau, dann könnt ihr mal auf Pause drücken, falls ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt. Im App-Store gibt es unter dem Namen Blinkenlight Stereoskop eine entsprechende Applikation fürs iPhone oder natürlich den iPod Touch. Und das Ganze ist ein Echtzeitsimulator unserer Installation. Das heißt, das Programm, wenn man es startet, verbindet sich mit einem von mehreren aufgebauten Servern, die von uns mit dem Echtzeitdatenstrom der Animationen, also das, was wirklich auf dem Haus läuft, wird dahin geschickt und kann man dort eben sehen. Und dann sieht man sozusagen live, was auf dem Haus abgeht. Aber es ist halt eine richtige 3D-Applikation, wo man dann so schön mit dem Finger hin und her drehen kann. Eine bemerkenswerte Applikation, wie ich finde, bedient sich wirklich super. Ein Werk von Dominik und Martin, auch bekannt als die Coding Monkeys, in der Macintosh-Szene sehr wohl bekannt. Und die haben hier echt Außergewöhnliches geleistet, wie im Übrigen auch eigentlich alle anderen im Team. Aber das war definitiv beeindruckend zu sehen, mit welcher Qualität sie das vor allem finalisiert haben. Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch für den Mac den gleichen Simulator. Also wer jetzt kein iPhone, ein iPod hat, sondern den Mac kann sich bei blinkenlights.net auch den Macintosh-Simulator mit derselben Optik runterladen. Das haben die dann auch noch am letzten Tag fertiggestellt. Und der verhält sich im Prinzip genauso.
Den habe ich jetzt gerade offen. Ich habe mich noch eine Zeit lang... Es gibt noch einen Live-Video-Stream bei... Wie heißen die gleich? Bei Ustream. Den habe ich meine Zeit lang neben dem Simulator gehalten und habe mich wirklich sehr gefreut, dass ich da fast das gleiche Bild sehe.
Mit ungefähr 6 Sekunden Delay.
Und wie ist denn das? Also diese Software... Ich habe das Programm jetzt offen, da sehe ich jetzt unendlich viele Live-Feeds. Sind das alles die gleichen Daten auf verschiedenen Servern?
Ja, das sind alles die gleichen. Wir hatten vorher aufgerufen, dass die Leute sich so ein Winkenproxy installieren. Das ist ein kleines Ruby-Script, das wir gehackt haben, was Dom gehackt hat, genau zu sein. Und das funktioniert bei uns einfach so. Wir haben hier einen Computer, auf dem fließen die ganzen Animationen zusammen. Da wird eine Playlist gemacht, und wenn Spiele gespielt werden, dann wird das alles zusammen gemixt. Und der daraus resultierende Grafik-Datenstrom, den schicken wir hier im Haus an die einzelnen Etagen, wo wiederum kleine Computer sitzen, die das über Ethernet empfangen, und dann per Funk an unsere Dimmer aussenden. So funktioniert die Installation. Und dieser selbe Datenstrom wird parallel noch an diese ganzen Proxys geschickt, sodass die mit demselben Datenstrom in Echtzeit versorgt werden. Das sind alles UDP-Pakete. Und damit empfängt man exakt das selbe wie das Haus. Das hatten wir schon im Nachgang zu unserer Pariser-Installation erfunden. Das ist nicht ganz neu. Wir haben das jetzt ein bisschen angepasst, weil sich unser Protokoll auch ein bisschen verändert hat. Damit erlaubt das sozusagen die Echtzeit-Teilnahme. Es gab da ja verschiedenste Kommentare im Upstore. Manche Leute mochten das, weil man eben auch mal sehr schön sieht, was mit 3D eigentlich so geht auf dem iPhone. Andere meinten halt, naja, das ist ja sinnlos. Na gut, das kann man so sehen, dass das sinnlos ist. Das ist jetzt keine Productivity-App, sondern das ist einfach wirklich nur genau das, was drauf steht. Es ist ein Echtzeit-Simulator. Nachdem wir hier abbauen, macht das in dem Sinne auch keinen Sinn mehr, auch wenn wir vorhaben, diesen Datenstrom weiter laufen zu lassen. Also wir wollen sozusagen diese Installation virtuell weiter am Leben erhalten und das vielleicht auch noch mal aufnehmen mit unseren alten Installationen, also mit Blinkenlights und Arcade, dass sie sozusagen einfach immer so virtuell laufen und dass man vielleicht auch wieder neue Movie-Submissions dafür annimmt, dass es einfach so ein virtuell konserviertes, aber sich trotzdem weiterentwickelndes Kunstwerk ist. Das dauert aber noch ein bisschen. Jetzt müssen wir hier erstmal einpacken und klarkommen und zu Hause ankommen, aber dann werden wir uns darum auch kümmern. Das ist die Technik, die wir hier aufgesetzt haben.
Wie war das denn? Lief das rein praktisch? Lief das den ganzen Tag über oder lief das nur in den Abendstunden, wenn es dunkel war?
Dieser Datenstrom läuft hier durchgehend, aber die Lampen sind tagsüber ausgeschaltet, weil hier auch noch Leute arbeiten. Abgesehen davon siehst du einfach diese Lampen nicht tagsüber. Wenn die Sonne aufgegangen ist, dann kommt so ein 150-Watt-Strahler einfach nicht gegen die Sonne an. Aber sobald Sunset ist, so fünf Minuten nach offizielem Sonnenuntergang, tritt das dann doch schon sehr deutlich hervor. Nachts ist das halt irre. Also wenn hier wirklich alle Lampen angehen an diesem Haus auf einmal, dann wird der Platz richtig hell.
Das konnte man im Livestream prima sehen. Das kriegt die ab, kriegt das natürlich nicht so mit von dem Lichteffekt, wenn alle Lampen angehen, aber im Livestream sah das ziemlich cool aus.
Ja, auch die Reflektion des einen Turms auf dem anderen.
Ich habe in dem Zusammenhang nochmal eure Videos angeguckt. Wäre schön, wenn wir die nochmal verlinken könnten zu der Aktion in Berlin bzw. in Paris. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hatte tatsächlich Tränen in den Augen. Ich habe das damals in Berlin mitbekommen, aber ich war echt so gerührt von dem Ganzen nochmal. Das ist wirklich eine großartige Sache. Ihr habt wieder Spiele dabei? Habe ich das richtig mitbekommen?
Ja, neue Spiele dabei, genau. Diesmal gab es sogar sechs Stück. Drei auf dem einen Turm, drei auf dem anderen Turm.
Lemminge habe ich gerade gesehen.
Lemminge laufen als Animation, aber nicht als Spiel.
Ich könnte jetzt in Kanada anrufen mit meinem iPhone und könnte jetzt darauf spielen, theoretisch? Im Simulator?
Du kannst diese Nummer anrufen. Wir haben jetzt leider keinen direkten VoIP-Zugang geschaltet. Jetzt geht es nur über Telefon. So eine von diesen müsste man mal, Sachen, die runtergefallen sind. Das kannst du machen und du müsstest dann eigentlich live auf dem iPhone oder Mac, auf dem Simulator das auch sehen, sofern die Spiele eingeschaltet sind. Soll ich mal gucken? Kann nämlich sein, dass die jetzt automatisch ausgeschaltet sind. Tagsüber wollen wir dann sozusagen nicht, dass die Leute anrufen und dann passiert irgendwie nichts. Aber für dich kann ich das ja gerne mal machen.
Das würde mich echt mal interessieren. Verdient ihr daran ein bisschen was oder verdient da nur die Telekom und O2 dran was? Die Telekom wahrscheinlich eher nicht, eher O2.
Der einzige, der da was dran verdient hat, ist der VoIP-Provider, weil der Telefondial-In geht halt über Voice-over-IP. Das ist so ein Asterisk-System, was halt für uns die Calls hier annimmt. Also wir haben hier zwei Computer im Prinzip, zwei PCs rennen diese ganze Installation. Das eine ist ein Rechner, der nur Asterisk macht und so ein bisschen Glucode, um das in unser Software-System einzubetten. Und der andere Rechner läuft halt diese Steuersoftware. Und das war's. Zwei PCs.
Ich leite mir gerade die Telefondummern runter, die es nicht einfach so gibt, sondern...
Als V-Card.
Genau, als V-Card. Was ist das für eine Vorwahl für Kanada?
Das ist ja hier alles ein Nummernraum. Und ich frage mich, wie lange der noch hält. Weil mit ihren paar Nummern... Technisch ist das ja hier alles so vorsinnflutig. Also man kommt sich so in Nordamerika doch schon echt komisch vor, wenn man so aus Deutschland kommt. Also allein diese Steckdosen. Diese ganze 110-Volt-Sache, das ist auch alles so minderwertig. Diese ganzen Stecker, die halten alle irgendwie nicht so richtig. Und auch so Mehrfachsteckdosen, das ist alles so ein Trash. Und es sieht einfach aus, als ob es einem gleich auseinanderfällt. Und das tut es eigentlich auch. Es gibt hier eigentlich sehr schwer wirklich hochwertiges Kabel- Und Steckerzeug zu kaufen.
Ich habe ihn gerade mal gespielt und dann stand sofort Game Over. Passierte gar nichts.
Was hast du denn gespielt?
Das ist ein einfaches Spiel, das ich jetzt auch hinkriege, damit ich mich nicht so komplett dämlich anstelle.
Tetris.
Irgendwas läuft da auch gerade. Ich kann dir Wackermole empfehlen. Das war eigentlich der totale Hit.
Okay.
Aber irgendwas steht da gerade. Ich habe das gerade nicht so im Blick, was da mit der Software ist.
Ach, ist das schick hier in Kanada anzurufen, um auf einem Simulator ein Spiel zu spielen. Das ist jetzt... Wie hoch ist dieses Haus?
Funktioniert es denn jetzt oder nicht?
Moll.
Kommt der Moll hoch?
Was muss ich da jetzt machen?
Dann tauchen sozusagen die Maulwürfe im 1-9 Raster des Keypads. Ah, einen habe ich erwischt! Genau, das Höchste, was ich gesehen habe, ist 44, glaube ich. Gut zu wissen, dass es läuft. Ich sehe das nämlich hier gerade gar nicht auf dem Display.
Wann kommt meine Punktzahl?
Gleich, na los, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Du hast jetzt live aus dem Fenster gekoffigt, hoffe ich.
Nein, im Fenster sehe ich nichts. Ich habe natürlich auch den Simulator gestartet.
Die 198 Euro, die ich jetzt für dieses Telefonat investiert habe, müssen sich ja gelohnt haben.
Ich habe es auch gesehen.
Hey, cool!
Also siehst du, das war halt so die Idee, dass man einfach so eine Installation, die eigentlich fest verwurzelt an einem Ort ist, weltweit erfahrbar macht. Das war eigentlich so der Plan. Und das ist, denke ich, ein Stück weit auch gelungen.
Habt ihr so Download-Zahlen für diese ganzen Sachen, für die App-Store-Sachen und für die Simulator?
Ja, aber die weiß habe ich leider nicht vorliegen. Also ich weiß, dass die App-Store, im App-Store, die war doch recht populär. Wir waren ja irgendwie auf Platz, also im deutschen iTunes Store waren wir auf Platz 3 der meist geladenen Programme für eine Woche.
Das ging relativ weit ober. Das war beeindruckend.
Und das bedeutet dann übrigens, dass das so ein paar tausend Mal pro Tag sind. Nur mal um so eine Dimension auch für diesen App-Store zu liefern.
Also ihr könnt schon sagen, es haben mehr Leute über den Simulator sich angeguckt, als tatsächlich live vom Haus waren.
Das kann man wohl so sagen. Wir haben auch mit diesem Proxy, der hat auch so die Möglichkeit mitzuzählen, wie viele Verbindungen er hat, aber ich kenne die ganzen Auswertungen nicht. Wir waren hier auch so erledigt nach der ersten Nacht. In den letzten Tagen haben wir es einfach ein bisschen lockerer angehen lassen. Ja, für den Macintosh war halt einiges dabei und fürs iPhone. Da haben wir uns bemüht, da haben sich natürlich jetzt eine Menge Leute beschwert, was ist mit Windows und was ist mit Linux. Da kann man nur zu sagen, man kann halt nur so viel programmieren, wie man programmieren kann. Wir hatten vor allem eben im Sinn, das iPhone mit einzubinden. Eigentlich wollten wir ja noch einen Schritt weitergehen und auf dem iPhone auch noch die Software so weit treiben, dass man eben auch direkt über das iPhone mit dem Haus interagieren kann.
Stimmt, irgendwie habe ich das gehört und konnte es mir nicht so richtig vorstellen. Aber das hat dann einfach nicht geklappt, ja?
Irgendwann war die Zeit dann einfach auch zu Ende. Ich meine, das Projekt ist sowieso unter Hochdruck entwickelt worden. Wir hatten hier nur fünf Monate Zeit, alles zu machen und dazu mussten wir überhaupt erstmal die ganze Technologie erfinden. Dann mussten wir sie herstellen, ja, also Platinen entwickeln, Platinen bauen, produzieren lassen, daraus wirklich funktionierende Geräte mit Gehäuse und Steckern machen. Das dann alles fertigstellen, hier auch die Planen, die wir an die Fenster gehängt haben, die Aufstellsituation und so weiter und so weiter. Da gehört ja ein riesiger Ratten-Schwanz an Details dazu. Und dann mussten wir das Ganze auch noch zwei Monate, bevor wir das hier in Betrieb genommen haben, auf ein Schiff verladen. Also wir hatten sozusagen eigentlich nur drei Monate Zeit.
Und in der Hoffnung, dass es durch den Zoll durchkommt, ist alles problemlos.
Sag mal kurz eine Zwischenfrage. Saat es eigentlich auf, also in real life sah es natürlich cooler aus als auf dem Simulator, ist schon klar, aber konnte man es in real life auch genauso gut erkennen oder geht es im Simulator ein bisschen besser?
Es geht im Simulator ein bisschen besser, weil der Simulator jetzt nicht in dem gleichen Maße das Nachleuchten simuliert. Das ist etwas, wo man den Simulator noch verbessern kann. Wir hatten das in unserem alten Blinkensim, hatten wir das schon mal drin, aber hier haben wir das so nicht drin. Das heißt, wenn jetzt hier ein Pixelwechsel ist, dann siehst du den halt sofort, wie das eben so ist auf dem Computer, aber tatsächlich hast du immer noch so ein bisschen das Nachleuchten der Lampen eigentlich mit drin. Das müsste man noch mit einmelden. Dazu kommt, dass man natürlich hier auf dem Simulator relativ leicht so eine ideale Position einnehmen kann. Das heißt, man guckt irgendwie von oben und nicht so sehr von unten vom Platz und man ist dann eben auch beliebig weit weg. Und wenn man richtig nah dran ist, dann ist es schon ganz anders. Also es erschlägt einen wirklich mit der Größe. Man muss schon relativ weit weggehen. Aber wenn man bis nach hinten, bis zu diesem Skywalk, da ist ja so ein Hochweg um diesen Platz herum. Das sieht man dann auch in dem 3D-Modell ganz gut. Wenn man da so steht, das war eigentlich ganz prima. Du kannst dir die ganzen Videos angucken, die jetzt so auf YouTube gelandet sind.
Wir haben noch irgendwie einen Link bei Twitter gepostet. Ah, jetzt ist es bei euch noch hell gerade.
Bei uns ist es noch richtig hell, weil hier haben wir ja sechs Stunden Unterschied. Bei euch ist es schon schön dunkel, aber hier ist gerade mal 15 Uhr und wir schalten erst die ersten zwei, drei Stunden wieder ab. Von daher ist das jetzt gerade ein bisschen fake. Die Playlist läuft natürlich, aber tatsächlich ist hier nichts zu sehen, weil es ja dunkel.
Also mein Spiel hat jetzt niemand gesehen live auf der Wand, das heißt, da muss ich noch mal ein paar Stunden anrufen.
Ich habe das gesehen live auf meiner Wand.
Stimmt, du hast es gesehen und Tim auch.
Alle anderen.
Ja, also ist es wahr. Wenn es auf dem Macintosh ist, dann ist es wahr.
Interessiert mich, ob das irgendwo in Kanada, Dinesien ist. Hauptsache ist es auf meinem Mac. Stimmt, da bist du recht.
Ja, also noch mal was zu dieser Wireless-Technologie. Da sind wir ja drüber eingestiegen. Das Besondere der Installation ist, dass wir halt diesmal auf Steuerverkabelung verzichten wollten, weil das einfach ein sehr, sehr zeitaufwendiger und fehleranfälliges Ding ist. Vor allem zeitaufwendig. Steuerverkabelung heißt, dass wir in Berlin und in Paris wirklich zu jeder einzelnen Lampe ein eigenes Adernpaar hingelegt haben, wo es dann an die Lampe ran ging, um der Lampe zu sagen, du jetzt an, du jetzt aus. In Berlin lief das alles noch mit mechanischen Relais. In Paris haben wir schon auf elektronische Relais umgeschaltet, haben das Dimming aber immer noch zentral koordiniert. Das heißt, der Rechner hat sozusagen realtime Timing gemacht und den Lampen exakt genau gesagt, wo sie in welcher Halbwelle einschalten und wieder ausschalten sollen. Und hier haben wir jetzt autonome Dimmer, die also wirklich direkt an der Lampe selber entscheiden, wie sie dimmen.
Das in Paris mit dem Strom mit den halben Takten, das hat ja nicht ganz so geklappt, deswegen habt ihr jetzt gewechselt, ne?
Das hat eigentlich wunderbar geklappt. Es gab nur dieses Problem mit der fünften Etage. Das haben wir ja dann auch in unserem Doku-Video ein bisschen gewürdigt, dass da der Fnord drin war. Was uns halt etwas auf die Füße gefallen ist, dass wir die Annahme gemacht haben, dass eine Lampe die Phase, also auf der Stromphase, an der wir sie einmal in Betrieb genommen haben, auch verbleibt. Und dann kam uns aber leider die Haustechnik dazwischen, die halt aufgrund wechselnder Belastungen dynamisch bestimmte Segmente auf andere Phasen geschaltet hat, um die Gesamtauslastung auszugleichen. Das Gebäude war einfach zu modern für unsere Annahmen. Und wenn dir halt unterm Arsch die Phase weggenommen wird, dann haust du halt so um 180 Grad daneben, sozusagen. Und das ist das Problem gewesen, was wir da hatten.
Das führte dann dazu?
Da konnten wir dann auch nichts mehr... Das führte dann dazu, dass wir sozusagen die Lampen falsch gedimmt haben, weil wir ihnen zu einem Zeitpunkt gesagt haben, du jetzt einschalten, wo sie nicht hätte eingeschaltet werden dürfen, und du jetzt ausschalten, wo sie nicht hätten. Das sieht man halt im Doku-Video, wenn du mal hinguckst. Bei vielen Sachen aus der Ferne gibt es dann so in der 5. oder 6. Etage in diesem Bereich immer so abstruses Zwischenflackern, was man so auf den ersten Blick nicht wahrnimmt. Aber das war halt genau dieser Effekt. Und das wollten wir eben jetzt komplett verhindern. Und das kannst du eben nur dadurch verhindern, dass du eben diese Synchronisation mit der Stromphase, also um da mal vielleicht etwas technischer zu werden, wer das nicht kennt, Strom ist halt so eine Sinuskurve. Und das heißt, du hast halt immer solche Energiehalbwellen, wo dann eben der eigentliche Strom kommt. Und du musst einen, um zu dimmen, quasi diese Halbwelle erstmal zurückhalten und schaltest dann eben zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt ein. So, das heißt, die ersten 50 Prozent der Zeit der Halbwelle schickst du noch keinen Strom durch die Lampe und dann schaltest du ein und dann hast du halt so einen 50 Prozent Dimming. Mal so ganz einfach gesagt. Und wenn dann halt das zum falschen Zeitpunkt passiert, weil einfach die Phase nicht mehr so ist, wie du es erwartet hast, dann bist du natürlich dumm dran. Deswegen will man das direkt an der Lampe da, wo wirklich der Strom kommt, in dem Moment auch immer wieder selber machen, sodass, wenn sich die Phase aus irgendwelchen Gründen ändert, dass der Dimmer das dann selber merkt.
Jetzt nochmal für ganz, ganz Dove. Ihr habt dieses Dimm so gemacht, in dem Strom eine Wellenbewegung ist, weil es ja Wechselstrom ist. Genau. Ihr habt dann quasi 50% Helligkeit geschafft, indem ihr einfach immer die Lampe nur für den kurzen Moment eingeschaltet habt, an dem die Welle gerade bei 50% war.
Ja, so funktioniert jeder Dimmer. Das ist jetzt kein Voodoo. Wenn du dir einen komischen Dreh-Dimmer in deiner Wohnung einbaust, das ist auch der Grund, warum diese Dimmer solche Geräusche machen. Insbesondere bei niedrigen Dimmstufen fangen die ja halt extrem an zu summen. Und das Summen kommt daher, du hast so diese Energie-Sinus-Kurve, und im Prinzip kannst du jetzt immer eine Halbwelle für sich betrachten. Wenn du 50 Hz Strom hast, heißt das, du hast so 100 Halbwellen pro Sekunde. 100 Mal hoch, 100 Mal runter, einmal hoch, einmal runter, ist sozusagen mal so eine Schwingung. Und davon hast du halt irgendwie 50, macht 100. Das heißt, du kommst auf eine Halbwelle auf so einen Zeitbereich von 10 Millisekunden. Also jetzt mal auf unser 50 Hz Stromsystem bezogen. Wir haben hier 60 Hz, da muss man sich entsprechend dann eben dynamisch nachrichten. Aber im Prinzip ist das das Gleiche, ich mach's jetzt mal für 50 Hz. Das heißt, du hast diese 10 Millisekunden, wo einmal die Energie sinusförmig ansteigt. Nach 5 Millisekunden kommt sozusagen am meisten Energie und in den nächsten 5 Sekunden geht das wieder nach unten. Das heißt, du hast so einen Energiewellenberg. Und diesen Strom schickst du durch den Glühdraht. Umso mehr Strom du durch den Glühdraht schickst, umso heller leuchtet die Lampe. Wenn du aber jetzt sozusagen nicht die ganze Halbwelle dadurch schickst, sondern nur die erst zur Hälfte sozusagen zuschaltest, wenn der Wellenberg ganz oben ist, dann kommt halt effektiv die Hälfte der Energie dieser Halbwelle da rein. Also schaltest du zu jeder Halbwelle ein zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt und umso weniger hell die Lampe leuchten soll, umso niedriger die Dimmstufe, umso später schaltest du ein. Und kurz vor dem Nulldurchgang, bevor die nächste Halbwelle beginnt, schaltest du dann sozusagen wieder aus. Genau.
Und mit anderen Worten, das flackert natürlich noch stärker als ein normales Licht schon flackert, aber das nimmt das Auge einfach nicht mehr wahr, weil es so häufig ist.
Richtig, das ist ja ein Glühdraht, also in dem Moment, wo du es ausschaltest, da geht er ja nicht wirklich aus, sondern dann wird er bloß nicht heller, sondern er glimmt dann sozusagen nach. Deswegen hast du eigentlich bei einer Glühdrahtlampe immer ein gleichmäßiges Licht. Anders ist es zum Beispiel bei Leuchtstoffröhren, das kennen wir alle. Wenn du eine Leuchtstoffröhre auf 50 Hertz betreibst, dann siehst du das halt. Deswegen hat man heute bei Leuchtstoffröhren, wenn man das zu Hause betreibt, im Idealfall so ein elektronisches Steuergerät davor, die das Ding dann halt mit vielen 100 Hertz betreibt, sodass du das eben nicht mehr siehst.
Und bei Energiespulanten genauso.
Genau, das ist halt einfach das, was diese Steuerelektronik da leistet, dass du eben kein flacker Licht mehr hast. Früher hat man halt einfach Leuchtstoffröhre direkt an Strom angeschlossen und hat es halt geflackert. In Europa halt mehr als in Amerika, weil hier hast du halt 60 Hertz. Trotzdem, das hast du wahrscheinlich auch noch gemerkt, bei Glüteradlampen tritt dieses Problem so nicht auf. Jetzt muss man nur noch ein bisschen, um das mit dem Dimmen noch mal abzuschließen, man muss halt so ein bisschen gucken. Natürlich ist die Rechnung jetzt nicht so einfach. 50 Prozent der Energie ist 50 Prozent Helligkeit. So einfach ist es nicht, weil natürlich so eine Lampe auch erstmal eine Weile braucht, bis sie sich hochglüht, beziehungsweise sie glüht halt auch nach. Letzten Endes, was wir hier gemacht haben, ist, wir sind erstmal von irgendwelchen Dimmenstufenverteilungen ausgegangen. Das heißt, wir hatten für jede Helligkeit erstmal eine Annahme. Und da kommt ja noch einiges dazu, zum Beispiel blickst du ja nicht direkt in die Lampe, sondern du schaust auf das Ergebnis, was die Lampe produziert, einen Meter entfernt von dem Fenster und da ist nochmal so eine milchige Plastewatt. Also ihr hattet so Baulampen? Genau.
So ganz knallhellen Scheinwerfer, die man am Baumarkt kriegt, relativ günstig. Die habt ihr dann gerichtet auf das Fenster. Vor dem Fenster hing aber noch eine Plane davor, oder ein Plastik in dem Fall. Genau. Und auf dieses Plastik hat es dann sozusagen draufgescheint, damit das dann so ein bisschen aussieht wie beim Duschvorhang.
Genau, und da geht natürlich auch nochmal Helligkeit bei verloren, ist ja klar. Sodass das Endergebnis unten auf dem Platz nochmal ganz anderen Regeln gehäucht. Genau, und dann haben wir das Display kalibriert und haben sozusagen eine Gamma-Tabelle gemacht. Und das ist auch wieder sehr schick, da ist der Dom wieder vorangeschritten und hat eine Applikation fürs iPhone gehackt, die jetzt nicht im App Store ist, sondern die nur hier lief, wo du sozusagen 16 Slider hattest für jede Helligkeit-Stufe. Und dann lief halt so ein Test-Movie, der immer so die Helligkeiten durchgesteppt hat. Und dann konnte man eben schön vor dem Haus stehen, mit W-Lan, mit dem Haus verbunden, die einzelnen Helligkeitsstufen mit dem Finger so hin und her schieben, bis die Helligkeitsverteilung eben so war, wie man sich das vorgestellt hat.
Musstet ihr das noch für die einzelnen Etagen unterschiedlich machen oder für die einzelnen Pixel? Oder reichte das dann einmal für die gesamte Wand?
Das reichte einmal für beide Wände, ja.
Okay, also das war jetzt nicht nochmal so jede einzelne Pixel-Kalibrieren und so und nächtelang dastehen.
Wobei man das schon, theoretisch könnte man das ja auch noch so machen, dass man das auch noch an die Außenhelligkeit anpasst, wie man das ja bei einem Bildschirm, den man kalibriert, auch macht. Du hast unterschiedliche Kaliberationsstufen.
Oder bei so einem MacBook-Punk.
Genau, haben wir jetzt nicht gemacht, weil die Phase ist dann doch relativ kurz und darauf kommt es nun wirklich nicht an. Theoretisch wäre das aber vorstellbar gewesen, dass man eben sagt, okay, jetzt von Sonnenuntergang bis eine Viertelstunde danach haben wir halt die Gamma-Tabelle, danach haben wir die Gamma-Tabelle. Das ist sozusagen die Lampen, so lange es hell ist, auch insgesamt heller leuchten. Aber das bringt dann nicht so viel, weil bei 16 Graustufen sind die Unterschiede schon so gering.
Kann das sein, dass wir gerade mal wieder Darth Vader in der Leitung mit haben? Das ist einer von euch reinatmet gerade?
Das ist Dennis Vader.
Gar nicht.
Muss sein Mikrofon ein bisschen weiter weghalten. Oder die Luft anhalten.
Glaub ich schon, aber ich muss gerade mal wieder atmen nach einer Stunde.
Okay, einmal pro Stunde darfst du für drei Minuten, aber nur.
Haben wir denn schon eine Stunde durch? Ja. Also so funktioniert das hier. So mit dem Blinken.
Und gab's wieder, woher kam die Animation? Die Animation habt ihr euch zuschicken lassen?
Also man konnte und kann auch immer noch Filme über blinkenlights.net einfach submitten. Vielleicht nochmal zu den Werkzeugen, die wir gemeint haben.
Ach, Augenblick, du hattest gerade einen CCC-Apfel.
Wir haben ja diesmal alles auf, wir haben sehr viel Mac-Technologie benutzt, so zum Ärger einiger. Aber das hatte natürlich auch einen Grund. Und der Grund war natürlich jetzt nicht irgendwie Apple zu huldigen, sondern schlicht und ergreifend die Erkenntnis, dass wir da in der Summe am meisten Kompetenz hatten. Also es gab hier fast niemanden in dem Projekt, der keinen Macintosh hatte. Oder gab es überhaupt jemanden? Doch, ich glaube, einer hatte glaube ich keinen.
Schreibt mal an Apple, das sollen die in ihre Hotnews packen.
Ach, die sind doch doof.
Die sind zu doof.
Ich bin hier sogar zum Apple Store gerannt. Der ist hier irgendwie quer über den Platz in diesem Einkaufszentrum. Hab denen irgendwie die Applikation gezeigt. Hab gefragt, ob sie nicht mal irgendwie Bock hätten, noch mal so ein paar iPhones irgendwie rauszutun. Und dann meinte ich so, naja, wenn ihr das machen würdet, dann würden wir vielleicht auch noch so eine Applikation schreiben, mit der man auf dem Haus rummalen kann. Und dann war das schwierig, wenn wir irgendwie irgendwas, was nicht im App Store abgesegnet ist, auf iPhones zeigen, dann werden wir morgen alle entlassen. Das hat er mir auch mit so einem Blick gesagt, dass ich ihn voll abgenommen habe. Ja, von daher, das war ein bisschen schwierig. Aber das ist natürlich klar, so ein Apple Store, das sind halt auch alles nur Sales-Droids.
Klar.
Da kann man jetzt keinen großen Marketing-Unterstützung erwarten.
Aber ich meine, das dürfte, das dürfte eine der größten Quartz-Composer-Installationen aller Zeiten sein, oder? Das ist doch Quartz-Composer. Ah, jetzt kommt da irgendwelche Flüssigkeit rein. Habt ihr dieses iBeer-Programm nachgebastelt?
Irgendjemand hat sowas mit Gesicht und Wasser gemacht. Das ist sehr schick.
Wenn ich den Turm jetzt umkippen würde, dann würde das Wasser auskippen sehen.
Also vielleicht erst noch mal was kurz zum Ansatz, um auch mal unsere Ideenlage da sozusagen zu verdeutlichen, warum wir das jetzt so gemacht haben, warum wir so viel Macintosh da zum Einsatz gebracht haben. Also alle im Team, die halt irgendwie kreativ an diesem Projekt gearbeitet haben, arbeiten sowieso alle mit Macs. Das heißt, es war einfach klar, der Macintosh war bei uns einfach die Basis. Dabei ist das jetzt nicht gerade so eine Gruppe von vollständig Apple-verblendeten Leuten, das ist einfach nur so, ihr kennt doch den Effekt, die Leute kaufen sich jetzt einfach MacBooks. Das ist jetzt einfach mal der Default-Laptop-Computer. So, dann haben wir eben überlegt, was können wir bieten, was wirklich eine gute Testplattform ist, um solche Animationen zu machen. Und es war klar, wir wollten diese iPhone-Applikation machen und es war auch klar, dass wir relativ easy, also relativ in Anführungsstrichen, diese Simulator-Code auf dem iPhone dann auch wieder zurück auf den Mac portiert bekommen. Das heißt, wir konnten eine Simulator-Umgebung bieten, wo man das wirklich so sieht, wie es am Ende ist. Weil das war ja diesmal nicht so einfach. Dadurch, dass diese Fassaden gekrümmt sind und man eben von jedem Punkt, je nachdem, wo man steht, was anderes sieht, mal den linken Turm, mal den rechten Turm, braucht man einfach so eine 3D-Visualisierung, um das wirklich zu begreifen. Und der schnellste Weg dahin war unserer Meinung nach Quartz Composer, was so eine der vollständig verkannten Technologien auf dem Mac ist, die glaube ich auch nicht, vielleicht nicht allen unseren Hörern wirklich geläufig ist. Also wenn man das Development Kit installiert, dann kriegt man eben auch noch diese Quartz Composer Anwendung mit dazu. Und das ist halt ein System, wo man einzelne Module mit Input und Outputs miteinander verbinden kann, wo man so ein Dataflow-Diagramm quasi erstellt und damit Grafik machen kann.
Also es lohnt sich wirklich, ich kann das an der Stelle nochmal empfehlen, auch wenn man gar nicht programmieren will oder sowas, dafür mal die Developer Tools zu installieren und mit diesem Quartz Composer ein bisschen rumzuspielen. Das macht echt Laune. Also man schmeißt da so Dinge rein, verschiedene Daten, RSS-Feeds und sowas und am Ende hat man einen Bildschirmschoner. Das ist der, der nicht das macht, was man machen wollte. Soweit bin ich nie gekommen, dass er wirklich das gemacht hat, was ich machen wollte. Aber das ist ganz großartig. Das ist mit Quartz Composer gemacht, diese ganze 3D-Animation.
Da kann ich übrigens auch noch was zu sagen. Kurz, nämlich erstens, das ist auch wieder typisch so ein Ding, was Apple eingekauft hat. Das hat nämlich ein Einzelner, glaube ich, programmiert irgendwann. Ich weiß nicht, wie es vorher hieß. Und Apple hat das gesehen, die haben den gleich weggekauft. Und auch, man kann halt, wie ihr schon erzählt habt, die Movies dann auch, also die Quartz Composer Movies, in QuickTime abspielen. Aber noch viel interessanter ist, dass man die als View auch in seinem Cocoa-Programm aufnehmen kann. Also auch jedes Programm kann einfach diese Quartz Composer-Sachen anzeigen. So kannst du, wenn du irgendwas schick aussehen lassen willst, musst du dann nicht schwer herum programmieren, sondern du machst alles in Quartz Composer und bindest das dann einfach in dein Programm ein. Also das ist eine total super Sache, habe ich aber auch bisher nur einmal benutzt für Spielereien.
Genau das haben wir auch gemacht, weil bevor jetzt dieser endgültige Simulator da war, hat Dom einen Simulator in Quartz Composer gemacht, als Plugin. Also wenn du dir von blinklights.net diese Creation Tools runter lädst, dann kriegst du halt für Quartz Composer, also erstmal so ein paar Composer-Dokumente, die wir sozusagen vorbereitet haben, wo schonmal alles so angeordnet ist, so als Beispiel, dass man eben sehen kann, wie man da schnell zum Zuge kommt. Und dann gibt es halt noch dieses Blinken-Poser-Plugin. Und das Ding kann halt erstens einen Grafik-Datenstrom nehmen, also so eine Animation, die du so als Input da reinläufst. Und dann generiert er erstmal das Blinken-Lights-Protokoll. Genau dasselbe Protokoll, was wir hier auch im Haus sprechen und was wir zwischen den Proxys sprechen und das, was letzten Endes bei dem Simulator ankommt. Und damit kannst du dann aus deinem Quartz-Composer-Dokument direkt eine Animation in den Simulator reinschicken. Und zwar sowohl in diesen schicken, richtigen 3D-Simulator, so mit dieser tollen Optik, als auch in so eine abgespeckte Version, die auch mit dabei ist. Die heißt dann Stereoscope Simulator QC. Und das ist genau das, was Denis gerade meinte. Das ist auch nichts anderes, als in einem Programm so ein Composer-View, der da so embedded ist. Und damit könnte man das eben auch schon mal ganz gut previewen, selbst bevor wir diese andere 3D-Anwendung fertig hatten. Und du kannst mit demselben Plugin auch gleich das Movie-Format schreiben, so dass wenn du dann fertig bist, dass du auch direkt damit aufnehmen kannst, dass du auch direkt mit dem Protokoll-Stream wieder empfangen kannst. Das hat am Ende wahrscheinlich nicht jeder vollständig verstanden, aber für uns war das ein super Entwicklungs-Ding, mit dem dann hier wirklich geile Animationen gemacht wurden.
Kurze Frage, habe ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden. Also auf dem Mac habt ihr den Quartz-Komposer eingebunden oder auf dem iPhone auch?
Ne, nur auf dem Mac. Also nochmal, es gibt den Stereoscope-Simulator fürs iPhone und für den Mac. Und die haben dieselbe Code-Basis. Die verwenden zwar eine andere 3D-Engine, aber im Prinzip ist das sehr ähnlich. Dann gibt es noch diesen Stereoscope-Simulator QC, der halt auf Quartz-Komposer aufbaut und der Teil von diesen Creation-Tools ist und mit diesem Plugin für den Komposer arbeitet. Den man sich eben auch direkt in seinen Dokument reinlegen kann und damit eben direkt Datenströme erzeugen kann und bzw. die Movies schreiben kann. So, und das war alles so, wie soll ich sagen, so performant und so cool und so einfach zu benutzen, dass wir einfach gesagt haben, ok, dann gehen wir da an der Stelle auch einfach Mac-only, weil die meisten Leute, die mit Grafik arbeiten und Animationen machen, haben eh ein Mac. Und die anderen Plattformen können wir einfach nicht bedienen, weil wir da einfach die Personalpower nicht haben. Es gab hier einfach niemanden, der die Hand gereckt hat und gesagt hat, das mache ich jetzt auch noch auf Windows. Das wäre halt einfach nicht zu leisten gewesen. Wir wollten dann zwar noch den alten blinken SIM, der allerdings keine 3D-Views unterstützt, auch noch anpassen an die neuen Protokolle, aber auch da sind wir nicht zugekommen, weil wir einfach so viel mit Debugging und Verbesserungen an anderen Fronten zu tun hatten, dass es einfach untergegangen ist.
Wobei, irgendjemand hätte sich doch bestimmt gefunden, wer daraus ein Counter-Strike-Level macht, aus den beiden Häusern, oder?
Gut, die Gelegenheit gibt es immer noch. Nur weil das Haus abgebaut ist, muss es ja nicht gleich zu Ende sein dafür.
Ich habe davon gelesen, dass es früher bei der Berliner Variante auf jeden Fall möglich war, noch irgendwelche Liebesbriefe zu schicken, was ich neulich rumerzählt habe und prompt jemand getroffen habe, der jemand kannte, der sich darüber tatsächlich verlobt hat, über eure Blinkenleitswand. Gab es das diesmal auch oder nicht?
Gab es nicht. Haben wir leider auch nicht mehr geschafft, weil nachdem wir einfach alles zum Laufen bekommen haben, dann kamen wir eigentlich erst dazu, auch so ein paar alte Features wieder zu reimplementieren. Aber eigentlich wollten wir das von Anfang an nicht machen. Es gab ein paar Requests. Wir hatten das ja auch in Paris schon nicht gemacht, weil wir einfach gesehen haben und so ist es auch. Mit zwölf Tagen Laufzeit kommst du einfach nicht so weit. Klar, ein paar Leute hätten das jetzt benutzt, aber in Berlin war das ja seinerzeit der totale Knaller. Damals hatten wir ja 300.
Wie lange ging das insgesamt? Das war ewig, das waren Monate?
Knapp sechs Monate.
Sechs Monate, ich kann mich noch gut dran erinnern. Das war großartig.
5 Monate und 23 Tage, um es genau zu sagen. Stimmt. Und hier waren es halt nur wieder zwölf Tage, genauso wie in Paris, und das reicht einfach nicht. Ich meine, jetzt merken wir, dass es sich in Toronto gerade rumspricht wie Sau. Jetzt ist das so das totale Stadtgespräch. Das läuft hier jede Nacht bei CityTV. Das ist so ein typischer lokaler Fernsehsender, die den Bildschirm immer so aufgeteilt haben, wie ein Multimedia-Screen, wo links oben das eigentliche Fernsehprogramm ist. Dann hast du rechts so ein paar Weather-Widgets. Rechts unten haben sie immer noch so eine Kamera eingeblendet, wo sie regelmäßig Verkehrssituationen und Wetter-Situationen zeigen. Das heißt, die gehen sozusagen durch diverse Webcams die ganze Zeit im Kreis durch. Und eine dieser Kameras zeigt halt auf das Haus, auf die City Hall. Was sie normalerweise immer nur verwendet tagsüber, um das Wetter zu zeigen. Und nachts ist da nichts zu sehen. Aber jetzt haben sie das halt auch nachts mit in die Rotation mit reingenommen, womit man dann immer so alle paar Minuten auf diesem City-TV-Kanal, der hier auch in allen Bars läuft. Sie haben ja hier diesen Wahn mit diesen ganzen Riesenbildschirmen in den Bars. Und auch da kannst du halt sitzen beim Bier und regelmäßig siehst du halt Stereoskop. Das war schon ganz nett.
Wie ist denn überhaupt das Feedback so? Wie ist denn der allgemein freundliche Toronton-Toner? Wie reagiert der denn darauf?
Also, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Na ja, es kann ja sein, dass du irgendwelche schreischende Mädels gehabt hast. Irgendjemand, der zusammengebrochen ist vor lauter Glück. Jemand, der beim Wacke-Moll sich Pleite gespielt hat. Weiß der Teufel was?
So wie ich jetzt gerade. Na ja, Local Calls sind ja hier meistens kostenlos. Von daher kann das zu Recht keinen ruinieren. Und wir hatten ja hier auch keine 0190-Nummer am Laufen, wie damals bei BlinkenLights. Aber wir haben ein gutes Feedback bekommen. Also gerade hier zu Nuit Blanche war einfach eine Menge los. Der Platz war immer voll. Die Leute lagen da irgendwie mit dem Rücken auf dem Boden und guckten sich das die ganze Zeit an.
Ist es noch warm genug dafür? Oder hat sich da jemand in der Ecke beigetragen?
Es ist super Wetter. Wenn ich den Weather-Vidgets glauben darf, haben wir so in etwa ähnliches Wetter wie ihr gerade in Berlin. Also sonnig, warm, so zwischen 17 und 20 Grad.
Also so wie wir Wetter heute hatten, das war jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit.
Wir hatten heute 21.
Und Dienstag ist 23 Grad hier vorher gesagt. Also das Wetter ist auch wirklich irre in Toronto. Also hier haben die ganz, sehr unterschiedliche Jahreszeiten. Als wir hier so im Frühjahr herkamen, da war es noch recht chilly. Und alle sagten so, ja der böse Winter ist gerade vorbei. Vor ein paar Wochen hatten wir hier irgendwie noch einen Meter Schnee. Als wir dann im Juli kamen, war das hier der totale Hochsommer. 35 Grad, die Sonne brannte und es war scheiße schwül und schwitzig. Als wenn du gerade nach, keine Ahnung, Italien gefahren wärst. Und jetzt im Herbst, super wattiges, nettes, trockenes Wetter. Die ganze Zeit Sonnenschein.
So ein bisschen Indian Summer mäßig?
So nennt man das dann. Wobei der eigentliche Indian Summer jetzt erst noch so richtig beginnt, so mit dem Wechsel der Farben der Bäume, jetzt der Herbst-Einsatz.
Warum wollen die denn die Installationen nicht länger fahren, oder sogar behalten oder so? Wenn das sowieso eh nur nachts läuft, dürfte das doch keinen Stern nach.
Na ja gut, tagsüber hängen die Planen ja auch und versperren sozusagen sämtlichen Mitarbeitern des Rathauses den Blick nach draußen. Und das kostet ja sozusagen auch der laufende Betrieb. Ich meine, es war von uns schon erkämpft, dass wir überhaupt eine Woche länger laufen, da wir eigentlich im Rahmen der Nuit Blanche hier ausgestellt haben. Und die läuft ja eigentlich nur eine Nacht. Das ist ja das Konzept. Aber wir haben halt denen gesagt, eine Nacht könnt ihr komplett vergessen. Also wenn wir kommen, dann muss das schon mindestens noch eine Woche länger laufen. Und so haben wir es ja in Paris auch gemacht.
Ich traue mich gar nicht zu fragen, aber wer bezahlt das Ganze? Also das sind ja Kilometer. Also ich weiß nicht, habt ihr da kilometerweise Kabel? Das sind 940 Transistoren. Das muss ja ein Vermögen kosten, überhaupt das Ganze rumzuschiffen. Wer bezahlt das denn?
Na, das ist halt die Nuit Blanche. Das ist halt so eine Kunstnacht. Und die holen sich ihre Kohle hier im Wesentlichen von einer Bank. Deswegen hat das ja hier auch so ein Branding. Also offiziell heißt das halt Scotiabank, Nuit Blanche. Das ist halt so. In Nordamerika hat alles immer gleich so ein Firmenstempel drauf. Da sind sie zwar nicht besonders glücklich mit, aber bisher haben sie sich auch noch nicht so ganz getraut, vollständig das sozusagen unter ihre eigenen Fittiche zu nehmen und darauf zu verzichten, dass da jetzt irgendjemand eben noch so seinen Stempel aufsetzt. Überlegen aber darüber. Und naja, gut, aus diesen ganzen Sponsorships haben sie das eben zusammengetragen. Den Rest trägt die Stadt selber. Und da gibt es dann halt die entsprechenden Fundings für die einzelnen Künstler. Natürlich waren wir hier mit Abstand das teuerste Projekt. Aber wir waren auch mit Abstand das sichtbarste und am meisten besprochenste Projekt.
Ich hab damals, als ich das Berliner Blinkenlides gesehen habe, hatte ich mir überlegt, dass man das... Was denn jetzt? Das sieht so aus, als ob das zu meiner Strömelive modulieren würden. Hast du irgendwas gemacht? Das wäre lustig, wenn ich meine Stimme sehen könnte auf dem Haus.
Der Simulator zippelt so ein bisschen, ne? Hatte ich auch gerade. Irgendwas geht nicht richtig.
Da wollte ich das ja zu Hause aus einem Billiregal selber nachbauen, am liebsten mit einem Computer. Und ich bilde mir ein, dass es irgendwann mal zu Chaos Congress auch einen Kurs gab, wo man das nachbauen konnte. So ein Lampenprojekt. Aber es war so unglaublich teuer, dass ich es gesagt habe, ne, mach ich dann lieber doch nicht. Wann wird es das Blinken-Lights-Selbstbauprojekt bei IKEA gehen? Fürs Billiregal?
Na, es gibt ja diverse Nachbauprojekte schon seit Ewigkeiten. Bloß keines davon war jetzt von uns initiiert worden. Aber es gab ja diverse Nachbauten. Das ist ja auf jedem Kongress. Wenn du da irgendwie in den Kongress reinlatsch, dann hatten wir da schon immer diverse Blinken-Lights und Arcade-Replika in allen Größen, Formen und Farben. Da wir ja alles open sourcen, konnte ja da eine ganze Menge wiederverwendet werden.
Aber ihr seid die Einzigen, die das auch so in diesem Rahmen machen, also die das so groß machen? Oder gibt es auch noch irgendwo in Südafrika Häuser, auf denen sich sowas abspielt oder sowas, von denen wir jetzt bloß nichts von haben?
Ja, wir sind nicht die Einzigen. Ich meine, wir sind sicherlich jetzt die Ersten gewesen, die halt dieses Ding mit Spielen auf dem Haus mit Telefon gemacht haben. Und das war ja offensichtlich so ein Katalysator, der dazu geführt hat, dass das einfach nochmal ganz anders wahrgenommen wurde. Das war halt nicht einfach nur so auf dem Haus irgendwas. Es gab vorher zwei, drei Kunstprojekte, die das auch schon mal so ähnlich gemacht haben. Also es gab schon 93 am MIT irgendwelche Verrückten, die einfach so Weihnachtsschläuche, weißt du, diese blinke Schläuche, die man immer so aufhängt, haben sie einfach so in die Fenster gehängt und das damit dann gemacht und dann auch irgendwie mit Relais. Leider war die Webseite nicht so auskunftsfreudig, um genau sagen zu können, wie das funktioniert hat. Später haben sie dann so einen VU-Meter gebaut. Da war ja auch erst 93. Wie meinst du das?
Da gab es keine Webseiten.
Sehe ich da jetzt gerade den Totenkopf?
Ja, es gab schon eine Webseite dazu, aber 93 gab es. Natürlich gab es 93 Webseiten. Na, beim MRT schon. Wie auch immer. Ich weiß ja nicht, wann die Webseite aufgesetzt wurde. Es gab halt darüber relativ wenig Bilddokumente und relativ wenig Erklärungen. Ein VU-Meter gab es später. In Delft wurde was gemacht mit einem Tetris auf dem Haus, aber das wurde halt nur per Telnet gesteuert. Das war halt so ein bisschen nerdy. Wir haben ja nie von uns behauptet, dass wir die Ersten waren, die das Konzept gemacht haben. Bisher sind wir enttäuscht.
Es bleibt trotzdem eine großartige Aktion.
Wir waren nicht die Ersten mit der Idee, ein Haus in ein Bildschirm umzuwandeln. Ich finde diese Idee als solche nicht so außergewöhnlich. Das Einzige, wo wir wirklich die Ersten waren, waren, dass wir Spiel und Telefon verbunden haben. Dass wir einfach etwas genommen haben, was jeder in seiner Tasche hat, mit dem er das fernsteuern konnte. Das war natürlich auch ein bisschen die Gnade der späten Geburt an der Stelle. Aber so war es nun mal.
Jetzt, wo man auch noch ein bisschen hört, von den ganzen Tetris-Spielen, die aus dem App-Store zurückgezogen werden müssen, weil die Tetris-Company sich dahinterlegt. Ihr habt da einen Tetris auf der Wand, hat sich die Tetris-Company bei euch gemeldet und Millionen verlangt?
Noch nicht.
Aber ihr hofft, es bleibt dabei, dass sie es tolerieren?
Ja, ich hoffe, dass sie nicht so den Arsch zugekniffen haben, dass sie uns da noch Stress machen. Wobei, man kann das nicht ausschließen. In Paris wollten uns auch so ein paar komische Leute ans Bein pinkeln mit irgendwelchen Bildern, die wir gezeigt haben.
Da hat ihr noch irgendwie Enterprise drauf abgespielt oder sowas auf der Leinwand?
Wir haben mal eine Folge von Futurama geguckt. Nee, hatten wir letztes Mal schon.
Ist ein bisschen so wie auf einem ganz großen Handy-Display, nehme ich mal an. Auf einem schlechten Handy-Display.
Ja, man konnte das nicht wirklich gut gucken. Wobei wir da, glaube ich, bei Akkade hätten wir sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen was rausholen können, indem wir da so eine Gamma-Justierung gemacht hätten. Wenn wir da so eine Gamma-Justierung gemacht hätten, wie wir das hier gemacht haben. Dass man wirklich das so aus der Ferne interaktiv ändern konnte. Das war hier eine Neuigkeit.
Diese Gamma-Level-Einstellung. Wobei damals gab es ja auch gar kein mobiles Internet, oder? Das ist doch alles schon so lange her, bestimmt schon fast drei Jahre.
Na damals hatten wir, also wir hatten schon ein Remote Debugging-Interface, aber das lief dann halt damals auch nur übers Telefon. Das heißt, du kannst dann so ein Pixel, das sieht man auch in dem Akkade-Video, kannst so ein Pixel übers Haus steuern, dann zählt da immer mit, in welchem Haus das ist. Damit konnte man sozusagen sicherstellen, dass eine Lampe auch wirklich, die da aufblinkt, auch wirklich die ist, von dem man denkt, dass man sie gerade angemacht hat, nicht dass da irgendwelche Kabel verdreht waren und solche Sachen. So was Ähnliches hatten wir hier auch, aber durch die Wireless-Technologie haben wir hier mit ganz anderen Problemen zu kämpfen gehabt. Da war jetzt so das nicht mehr ganz so entscheidend.
Das fällt mir gerade auf. Hattet ihr das schon fertig, das Programm, mit dem man auf der Leinwarte einen Finger auf dem iPhone hätte malen können und man hätte seinen Finger sofort auf der Wand gesehen?
Ne, das hatten wir nicht fertig.
Ah, schade. Das wäre natürlich nochmal noch großartiger gewesen.
Wir haben halt mit dem Simulator angefangen und wie das immer so ist, die Dinge ziehen sich ewig hin und bis es dann halt alles lief, war dann einfach die Zeit weg, da so ein Real-Time-Painting zu machen. Aber das ist definitiv eines der Features, die wir beim nächsten Mal in Angriff nehmen werden.
Das ist doch dann der Godlike-Mode, wenn man so einen Finger nimmt und den so über sein Telefon zieht und dann erscheint das auch schon am Auswand.
Insofern gab es hier auch einige Missed Opportunities, die einfach der kurzen Vorbereitungszeit und den geringen finanziellen Ressourcen, die wir leider nur hatten, geschuldet waren. Also mit ein bisschen mehr Zeit, einen Monat mehr Zeit und einen Tick mehr Funding und wir hätten sicherlich noch einiges losreißen können. Aber so war es einfach mal wieder ein Projekt, was von sehr viel freiwilliger Bereitschaft von vielen Leuten im Team getragen war. Und man kann einfach Leute, die sich sowieso schon jede Zeit, die sie auch nur einen Hauch übrig haben, da mit ins Projekt einbringen, auch nicht beliebig treten. Da muss man einfach gucken, was kommt und was wird und das, was halt nicht klappt, das klappt dann halt nicht. Aber wir haben immerhin mit diesem Wireless, ich meine, das ist jetzt insofern auch wieder Novum. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt so die erste Installation dieser Art, die halt mit Funk-Technologie arbeitet. Wir haben es halt geschafft, mit diesen Wireless-Dimmern, mit diesen WDM-Dingern eine Technik zu entwerfen, mit der man halt so eine Hausbespielung tatsächlich machen kann. Trotz dieser ganzen Problematiken mit der Verseuchung des 2,4 Gigahertz-Bereichs, und so weiter.
Genau, hattet ihr damit Probleme, wenn irgendjemand seinen WLAN-Laptop eingeschaltet hat, was ja im selben Frequenzbereich ist wie eure Funk-Technik, dass das dann irgendwelche Probleme gab, irgendwelche Einspritzer oder sowas, oder ging das so halbwegs?
Das lässt sich so einfach nicht beantworten. Also es gab grundsätzlich, gibt es einfach bei Wireless das Problem, dass du es mit Übersprechen, Interferenzen, Verdeckungen, Reflektionen und solchen Effekten zu tun hast. Und das ist auch keine konstante Geschichte. Das funktioniert in einem Moment so und im anderen Moment so. Und die eigentliche Schwierigkeit, mit der wir vor zwei Wochen, als wir noch darüber gesprochen haben, dass wir Probleme haben, womit wir gekämpft haben, war, das Sende-Protokoll so zu gestalten, dass das sozusagen da einfach durchpflügt. Dass das so robust ist? Genau, dass man einfach eine robuste Übermittlung hat von dem Sender zu den Empfängern, obwohl die halt sehr weit auseinander stehen, da eine Gebäudekrömmung mit drin ist, du da diese ganzen Cubicles von diesen Offices mit drin hast, da Zeug rumsteht, unglaublich viele Flanken und Trennwände usw., die halt irgendwie reinstreuen. Dann haben die Leute natürlich noch W-Lans offen, Bluetooth am Start, weiß, 2,4 Gigahertz, ist halt unreglementiert. Von daher kann dir alles dazwischen funken. Dann muss man eben auch gucken, sendet man vielleicht sogar zu stark, also überreißt man das Signal oder sendet man zu schwach.
Jetzt werden wir wieder gerekrollt.
Und das war glaube ich auch ein First, also ein Rickrolling in der Größe. Muss uns erstmal einer nachmachen.
Rickrolling ist dieser Begriff für, wie heißt der Typ? Ich bin zu jung dafür.
Ach komm, alle Fans von Rick Astley waren jung. Du kennst das Phänomen Rickrolling nicht?
Ich kenne das Phänomen, ich wusste, wie schwer das ist. Ich wollte es jetzt einfach nochmal kurz erklären für die Leute, die zuhören, weil vielleicht die das ja nicht wissen.
Also Rick Astley war in den 80er Jahren einer dieser Pop-Phänomene, der aus dem Nichts kam und dann 2-3 Hits gelandet hat. Vor allem dieses Never Gonna Give You Up war der totale Hit. Dazu gibt es auch noch dieses Video, wo er wie ein Berserker rumzappelt. Irgendwie hat sich in den letzten Jahren wieder geboren, wahrscheinlich aus diesem V-Chan-Imageboard, wo alle Internet-Meme dieser Zeit eigentlich herkommen. Da hat sich dieses Rickrolling entwickelt, was bedeutet, man linkt auf irgendetwas, hat einen Hidden Link, was weiß ich, mit Tiny URL geht das ja heute ganz schön. Hier, keine Ahnung, das Passwort für die Mailbox von Gerhard Schröder. Und dann alle so, oh geil, klick. Und dann kriegt man aber einfach nur dieses Video von Rick Astley, wo er rumhampelt und das Lied singt. Und das nennt man halt Rickrolling. Man ist halt rickrolled, wenn man eben reingefallen ist, drauf geklickt hat und dann nur ein Rick Astley vor die Nase bekommen hat.
Und ihr habt jetzt dieses Video auf dem Haus gezeigt.
Genau, und davon Video gemacht, dass es dann auf Vimeo gelandet ist und irgendwie so mit, hier guck doch mal, erst so ganz mysteriös, geht dann irgendwie die Kamera nach oben und zeigt dann halt irgendwann das Ding.
Jetzt ist gerade ein schönes Video, wo oben auf dem Bildschirm, also es sind ja insgesamt quasi vier Bildschirme, wo oben auf dem Bildschirm einer hüpft und unten fallen die ganzen Steine runter.
Genau, das ist ganz, ganz toll. Das ist von einem anderen Tim aus Berlin gemacht, sehr schick. So, das finde ich auch ganz toll, weil das eben so mit dieser Idee des Gebäudes an sich spielt. Also wo man...
Ah, der ist sogar noch auf dem zweiten Haus...
.Film nimmt und den anzeigt. Genau, der geht auch aufs andere Haus rüber. Er wechselt die Türme und er läuft auf dieser Trennung zwischen diesen beiden Screens hin und her. Das ist so ein mechanischer Raum. Das ist halt Klimaanlage. Technical Rooms sind das. Klimaanlage, Fahrstühle, Schnickes und so weiter.
Die da auf halber Höhe des Hauses sind sozusagen, wo es keine Feste gibt.
Genau, auch noch mal oben, aber eben auch in der Mitte. Das ist das Haus einfach gebaut. Das war früher ja ganz typisch für diese Bautechnik. Und die konnten wir natürlich nicht nutzen. Aber wir haben halt, wir sind alle davon ausgegangen. Also wir haben ja dieses Konzept der virtuellen Matrix. Wir haben ja gesagt, okay, wir haben zwar 960 Pixel, aber wir definieren eigentlich eine Matrix, die viel, sehr viel größer ist. Nämlich 96 mal 32 Pixel. Die Größe haben wir so gewählt, dass das im Prinzip einem, wenn du dir vorstellst, du nimmst jetzt so ein DIN A4-Blatt und rollst das zu so einem Zylinder zusammen. Und steckst das dann quasi in der Mitte auf dieses UFO drauf. In dem Haus. Das heißt, diese virtuelle Matrix umschließt sozusagen dieses UFO komplett und ist so eine Art 360-Grad-Screen. Bloß du siehst halt nur die Pixel da, wo eben dahinter auch ein Fenster ist. Aber wenn du halt das Blatt auffaltest, hast du eben diese volle breite Matrix. Und so kann man eben auf einer einzigen Matrix Filme machen, aber man hat halt nur diese vier Screens, eben diese Türme des Gebäudes, wo man dann eben auch wirklich was sieht.
Also man maskiert den Rest sozusagen.
Genau, das ist eine Maske. Und das war eben so unsere Annahme, dass man so eben sehr schöne Animationen aufs Haus bringen kann und dass es am Ende überhaupt nicht stört, dass man Teile davon nicht sieht. Das hat sich auch bewahrheitet. Also es gibt viele Filme, die halt einfach die ganze Matrix bespielen und es sieht trotzdem cool aus, wenn man drauf schaut. Trotzdem ist es noch cooler, wenn Filme eben auch explizit für diese vier Öffnungen, für diese Maske speziell gemacht sind und dann eben auch mit dieser Idee spielen, dass sie sich wirklich auf diesem Haus abspielen. Wie zum Beispiel dieses Männchen, das rumläuft und oben in dem Screen rumhüpft und unten fallen halt die Brocken runter.
Hast du einen Lieblingsfilm?
Ja, der gehört auf jeden Fall dazu. Ich finde die Lemminger auch super.
Ah, jetzt kommt gerade die Lemminger.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht so einen super Mega-Favoriten. Ich finde, dass einiges sehr gut gelungen ist. Aber der junge Mann, der da die Brocken raustritt, den finde ich schon ziemlich gut.
Ah, und da dicken so die Lemminger. Schick. Wie ist denn das? Also ganz ehrlich, in dem Moment, in dem, wie gesagt, du standest beim letzten Mal schon ein bisschen unter Stress, würde ich sagen. Also unter positiven Stress auf jeden Fall. Und wenn es dann das erste Mal so richtig, richtig läuft, was ist das für ein Gefühl? Ich meine, du hast jetzt schon ein Kind, du hast schon einen Sohn. Und ganz unter uns, was ist besser? Kind bekommen oder?
Was besser ist, Kind bekommen ist besser. Aber das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das ist doch ein großer Moment, in dem, wenn man da so die Wand vor sich plötzlich so eine Animation draufsieht.
Das ist schon cool. Wenn man so lange daran plant, und dann hast du einfach wirklich diesen Moment, wo du weißt, jetzt haben wir es aber auch geschafft. Die Scheiße funktioniert wirklich. Wir wussten einfach nicht, ob unser Plan wirklich aufgeht. Wir haben alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, und es war dann Hopp oder Top.
Und habt gewonnen. Aber es war nicht die ganze Zeit immer zwangsläufig so. Du warst schon ob die Miste spendetzt mal, aber schon so.
Jetzt müssen wir uns auch anschrecken. Solche Momente brauchst du auch. Du brauchst ja auch diesen Druck, um dann auch die entsprechende Konzentration aufzubringen. Auch schon allein. Ich habe diese Bugs da konkret nicht selber debuggt. Das war jetzt nicht mein Teil. Da hat der Daniel dran gesessen, und der Miloš, die haben da irgendwie gehackt wie die Wahnsinnigen. Der eine in Berlin, der eine hier in Toronto, und haben sich dann sozusagen gegenseitig immer so den Code zugespielt. Der eine ist dann mal kurz drei Stunden schlafen gegangen, und der andere hat weiter gearbeitet. Und so ging das dann über 24 Stunden und noch länger. Ich bin ja in Anführungsstrichen nur der Koordinator hier zusammen mit dem Fidel des Projektes. Wir haben uns halt alles ausgedacht und müssen halt vor allem dafür sorgen, dass hier die Bedingungen stimmen.
Hast du vielleicht noch mal Lust, ein bisschen über das Team zu erzählen? Weil man kriegt das ja nicht so mit. Man denkt ja klar, da stellt man so ein paar Lappen hin, und dann packt man einen Computer daneben, und das wird schon alles gehen und dann ein paar Kabel rausschmeißen.
Kann ich machen. Wir haben auch eine schöne Team-Seite auf der Webseite. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die schon entdeckt hast.
Ja, die habe ich schon entdeckt, aber ich wollte dich trotzdem noch mal dazu nachdenken, ein bisschen einfach.
Klar, kann man mal so durchgehen. Viele sind natürlich sowieso hier der Oberheld, also viele und ich, wir sind ja so die eigentlichen, wie soll ich sagen, wir sind so die ersten, die irgendwo hingehen. Wir planen das Projekt und wir planen die Dimension und suchen uns dann halt immer ein Team zusammen.
Ihr habt euch das immer mal beim Bier überlegt, dieses Blinkenlaut zu machen, vermute ich jetzt mal.
Na ja, das ist halt damals, als die Idee halt aufkam für die 20 Jahre CCC-Geschichte, hatte ich halt mal so diese Idee, man könnte ja da mal CCC ins Haus reinschrauben und dann wurde so die Idee so ein bisschen unter Freunde getragen und dann kam dann gleich der erste Kommentar, dann kann man ja auch gleich Tetris spielen. Und in dem Moment, wo dieser Satz gesagt wurde, gab es halt so einen Freeze-Moment, so dieses, dann so ja, was wäre wenn eigentlich? Und in dem Moment kam halt viele mit dazu und meinte, dem Ingenieur ist nichts zu schwör und viele ist halt so ein Universal-Talent, so der einfach Hardware und Produktion, da ist er einfach Spitze drin und hat auch eben die Liebe zum Detail auch, die wir glaube ich da an der Stelle auch total teilen und wir beide koordinieren halt das Projekt und dann haben wir uns halt viele andere Leute mit ins Boot genommen, manche waren halt letztes Mal schon mit dabei, manche sind neu dazugekommen.
Wow, die ist richtig lang geworden, die Liste, die war neulich noch nicht so lang, bilde ich mir ein.
Jaja, weil ja hier auch in Toronto noch einige dazugekommen sind. Da fehlt jetzt hier auch noch ein Bildchen. Es sind derzeit 22, da fehlt aber auch noch einer, also es sind eigentlich 23 Leute, die so mitgewirkt haben, wobei es natürlich dann auch noch viele Leute in der 2. und 3. Reihe gab, die eben auch Wichtiges dazu beigetragen haben. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir da hier mal durchgehen, das ist vielleicht auch nicht für jeden so interessant, aber Daniel und Milos, die jetzt hier in der Liste genannt sind, die haben halt vor allem diese Hardware, diese Wireless-Hardware entwickelt. Milos ist ja sehr bekannt im Club für seine Hardware-Designs, der hat auch schon dieses Sputnik-System entwickelt. Sputnik ist dieses Active RFID-System, das wir auf dem Kongress seit zwei Jahren im Einsatz haben, dieser kleine Blink Attack, mit dem jemand rumlaufen kann und wir erfassen ja die Bewegungen auf dem Kongress. Und sozusagen ein Überwachungs-Selbstbauprojekt, wir überwachen uns mal, um zu sehen, was man aus diesen Daten wirklich rausholen kann, um einfach mal eine Einschätzung machen zu können, was so Bewegungsprofile leisten können. Einerseits so spielerisch, um auch was davon zu haben, um einfach mal ein paar Daten zu gewinnen. Andererseits natürlich auch, um diese Problematik auch konkret mal belegen zu können, dass man eben aus solchen Bewegungsprofilen Informationen gewinnen kann, die man so auf den ersten Blick vielleicht nicht vermutet. So dieses, wer hat sich besonders viel mit wem getroffen und wer teilt sozusagen dein Interesse, weil er immer in den gleichen Konferenzräumen gesessen hat und so weiter. Das ist zuletzt auch nach New York getragen worden, auf der Last Hope, auf der Hacker-Konferenz von 2600. Da gab es dann auch ein cooles Team, die da komplett neue Software für entwickelt haben, die das auch tatsächlich mit dem Fahrplan verbunden haben, sodass sie dann wirklich so sagen konnten, wer hat sich vorher für eine Veranstaltung gemeldet und sie dann auch tatsächlich besucht und so ein Kram. Also richtig abgefahrene Scheiße, so Web 2.0-ig, schön mit Web-Frontend, ich hab das nur im Ansetzen gesehen. Ich hoffe, es ist schwer, dass die Jungs auch auf den Kongress kommen und es da wieder zum Laufen bringen.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen schäublich, ne?
Ja klar, aber ich meine, man kann Technologie immer kritisieren, so aus sich heraus, man kann sich aber auch konkret damit beschäftigen und auch was dazu wissen. Ich denke, das war auch immer der Ansatz im Club, dass man eben nicht einfach nur so aus dem Bauch heraus alles Scheiße findet, sondern dass man sich die Technik eben auch anschaut. Wie es immer so ist, Chancen und Risiken liegen eng beieinander. Du kannst mit dem Hammer irgendwie Schafe erschlagen, aber du kannst damit halt auch Nägel in die Wand treiben. Und da muss man eben auch sehen. Genau, wo kann man mit RFID Spaß haben und wo wird es ein Problem? Und so bringt man eben das eine mit dem anderen zusammen. Das Besondere an dieser Sputnik-Technik ist, dass sie komplett verschlüsselt ist, sodass wenn du deine Identität nicht preisgibst, sie dann auch kein anderer duplizieren kann. Von daher ist das System auch anonym. Also sozusagen ein anonymes Tracking. Es liegt an dir, wie weit du deine Anonymität aufdecken möchtest. Daniel und Milos haben vor allem diese DIMA zum Laufen gebracht. Milos hat die Hardware entwickelt, zusammen mit seiner Frau Freundin Britta. Daniel hat große Teile zu der Firmware beigetragen. Das war auf jeden Fall ein ganz wichtiges Standbein dieses Projektes. Die haben sich da auch wirklich den Arsch abgerackert. Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Dann hier, das habe ich schon mehrfach erwähnt, Dominik und Martin, die Coding Monkeys aus München, die das erste Mal dabei waren, die einfach eine enorme Leistung hingelegt haben. Insbesondere eben diese Simulator, die sie geschrieben haben für das iPhone, für den Mac, die ganze Quartz Composer-Suit und eben auch noch so mal nebenbei auch noch einen großen Teil vieler cooler Animationen, hier die Lemmings und so weiter. Das kommt auch alles von da. Also das war sehr, sehr, sehr hilfreich in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Dominik ist ja auch bei Bits und so dabei, ne?
Genau, ja, beide. Ja, Dom und Martin sind halt regelmäßige Bits und so Mitmacher. Das ist ja ein recht großes Team da. Aber das sind so die, seit, weiß nicht, seit Anfang an, glaube ich sogar schon, die Regulars und auch die, die da einfach am meisten technischen Plan haben, gerade was den Mac betrifft. Klar, sind ja auch Entwickler, bleibt nicht aus. Ja, dann gibt es hier die nächsten drei hier, Andrew, Dan und Jonathan. Das sind drei Jungs, die haben wir hier in Toronto getroffen bei unserem zweiten Treffen. Die haben uns irgendwie, einer hat uns angeschrieben, so ja, hier, er hätte gehört, BlinkLights käme in seine Stadt und er hätte ja schon von uns gehört und überhaupt. Und sowas wollte er ja schon immer mal machen. Dann haben wir uns mit ihm getroffen und haben festgestellt, die totalen Meganords. Also so richtig Coder von dem Herrn, Leute, die auch in Hardware und Software Plan haben und darüber hinaus auch noch so smooth und so freundlich und so genügsam und gruppenorientiert und kooperationswillig waren, dass sie ja gleich gesagt haben, ok, alles klar, ihr wollt euch hier irgendwie einbringen, dann doch gleich richtig. Die haben dann wirklich einen Großteil der Software geschrieben, die hier zum Einsatz kamen. Diese ganze Technik, mit der man sozusagen überhaupt erst mal mixen konnte. Früher konnten wir immer nur einen Film oder ein Spiel anzeigen. Jetzt läuft das ja gleichzeitig. Wenn deine Animation läuft und du spielst deinen Wacomole, dann wird das ja da drüber eingeblendet. Und du siehst da drunter noch die anderen Animationen laufen. Das ist halt so ein Multi-Layer-System, wo alles irgendwie gemixt wird. Das haben wir noch nicht so voll aus. Ja, das wird in Realtime in multiple Levels. Jeder Layer hat dann so bestimmte Attribute, ob er einen Schatten wirft oder ob er irgendwie durchsichtig ist oder den anderen komplett ersetzt. So eine Sachen.
Ihr habt quasi Quarz-Extreme oft auf dem Haus gemacht.
Ja, ganz soweit geht es nicht, aber es ist schon so ein bisschen Quarzig, so ein bisschen Multilayer halt. Das ist ja jetzt auch nichts...
Nichts Dramatisches, aber es ist schon...
Nö, aber es muss halt auch erstmal geschrieben werden.
Man muss es mal vergeben.
Da ist halt ein großer Teil. Dann haben sie auch unsere alte Telefonie-Geschichte, die damals ja auf ISDN basierte. Mit ISDN ist das ja hier nicht so toll. Dann haben wir das halt, wie schon erwähnt, auf Asteris umgestellt, das haben die auch noch gehackt. Das war auf jeden Fall ein super Beitrag. Echt spitzen Truppe und die werden uns auch erhalten bleiben. Ich hoffe, dass die auch auf den Kongress kommen. Wo wir übrigens planen, auch einen Vortrag zu machen. Mal gucken, ob er angenommen wird.
Oh, ich habe so eine Ahnung, dass möglicherweise schon.
Könnt ihr eine Chance haben?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Mein iPhone ist übrigens richtig warm geworden. Ich habe die ganze Zeit hier den Stereoskop laufen lassen. Es wird schon warm.
Na ja, da ist ja auch der 3D-Chip richtig am Start. Wenn normalerweise nicht alle Transistoren zum Einsatz bringen. Verwundert dich das? Grafikkarten waren schon immer heiß.
Okay, dann sind hier noch unglaublich viele andere Leute. Wer war die ganze Zeit, ihr seid die ganzen letzten Wochen in diesem Haus hoch und runter gerannt? Ihr seid wahrscheinlich mit den diversen Hausmeistern per Du mittlerweile?
Ja, hier kennen uns irgendwie alle. Die ganze Security und so.
Zu wie viel Räumen konnten die Schlüssel nicht mehr gefunden werden?
Du, was lachend hier, ist alles RFID-basiert. Wir haben hier einfach so Karten und dann macht es immer Piep-piep. Außer die Netzwerkräume, die haben auch eigene Schlüssel. Und die Sicherungskästen. Ansonsten können wir hier auch öfters gebraucht haben. Nö. Nix rausgeflogen? Beim Testen der Lampen hatten wir glaube ich eine, die hatte einen Kurzschluss, das war es dann auch.
Denis, dir geht es gut?
Man merkt es.
Ich muss mich nur aufrecht hinsetzen.
Das ist ein bisschen abgesackt. Ja, dann kann man hier noch den Falk auf jeden Fall erwähnen. Wir hatten ja hier am letzten Woche zu Nuit Blanche gab es ja dann noch ein Special. Wir hatten ja diesmal auch Sound. Das muss ich noch erwähnen. Wir hatten dann zu Nuit Blanche, leider nur zu Nuit Blanche ein großes Soundsystem auf dem Platz installiert. Und Falk hat dann Live-Vijaying gemacht. Das hatten wir in Paris schonmal für Akades, schonmal so experimentell auch gemacht. Da funktionierte das so ein bisschen. Da haben wir noch so eine Linux-Box gehabt, wo dann sozusagen der Video-Output aus seinem Mac gewandelt wurde von so einem Plugin, das jemand für einen M-Player geschrieben hat, der das dann wiederum in unseren Blinkenlites-Datenstrom umgewandelt hat, den wir dann per W-Lan aufs Haus geschickt haben und dann konnte er sozusagen live aufs Haus senden. Das war aber noch ein ziemlicher Umweg, weil man brauchte noch richtig Frame-Grabber-Karte und so ein Kack. Dieses Mal haben wir es anders gemacht. Falk benutzt eine wenig bekannte Software, weil das eben nur so speziell für VJs ist auf dem Mac, die heißt VDMX. VDMX ist der totale Mega-Live-VJing-Overkill. Also kannst du ja mal angucken auf der Webseite. WitzWox. Heißt du die Company?
Ich glaube, die heißt so.
Ja, das sieht hier bisher nach irgendwas Bösem. Genau, diese Software ist das und ganz böse. Und diese VDMX, die neueste Version, diese Beta-Version, die ist komplett neu geschrieben worden, Megaperformant für Quartz und OpenGL und hat auch ein Quartz Composer-Integration. Und damit konnten wir unseren Blinkenposer, unser Plugin für Quartz Composer, auch in diese Software mit reinstecken. Und damit konntest du mit dieser Software direkt aus dem Programm BlinkenLights-Protokoll sprechen und aufs Haus senden. Das heißt, wir haben dann einfach nur ein Kabel da unten hingelegt, also zur Sicherheit ein Kabel. Wir hatten zwar auch einen WLAN, aber darauf wollten wir uns dann nicht verlassen. Wir haben ein Kabel da unten hingelegt, in seinen Laptop reingesteckt und er konnte direkt aus dem Rechner heraus direkt auf unseren Bmix, also diese Software, die sozusagen alles zusammenmix, senden auf einen eigenen Layer, der alles andere überdeckt. Und dann konnte er eben live auf dem Haus VJen. Und da natürlich ein VJ, der jetzt wirklich Plan hat von Grafik und Kontrast und Helligkeit, ganz andere Einstellungsmöglichkeiten hat in Real-Time, vor allem wenn er direkt vor dem Haus steht, war das einfach kolossal. Dazu lief Musik, die extra für Blinkenlights komponiert wurde, für diesen Auftritt. Eine halbe Stunde Musik von der großartigen Truppe vom Kraftfutter Mischwerk, kraftfuttermischwerk.de. Die großartige Jungs, die tollen Sound machen, alles unter Creative Commons raushauen, da kann man sich das alles runterladen. Die Musik hier von der Party geht auch noch ins Blog. Hab ich noch nicht zugekommen. Das war natürlich dann hier das totale Highlight. Da war auch großes Trara und Hallo und Begeisterung auf dem Platz angesagt.
Wow, das klingt so, als ob es wahrscheinlich in einem Video auftauchen wird, aber nicht mal halb so gut sein wird in dem Video.
Das wird sich zeigen. Wir hatten natürlich hier wieder unsere Star-Dokumentatoren, Kirian und Michael Assistent, die auch schon die ganzen anderen Videos von BlinkNights gemacht haben. BlinkNights Arcade ist von ihr, die Camp-Doku vom letzten Jahr, der Kongress-Doku vom 23c3 ist von ihr. Man hat schon so einiges von ihr gesehen im CCC-Kontext. Macht einfach tolle Videos. Die waren vor Ort und haben hier 10 Tage Material gesammelt. Da werden wir hoffentlich bald das 3. Doku-Video raushauen. Dann hatten wir hier noch ein paar weitere Veteranen. Willow, die Freundin von Falk, die hat uns hier kräftig backstage-mäßig unterstützt mit Essen und sonst wie. Antenne hat Grafik gemacht. Papillon, unser Urgestein vom CCC, war natürlich wieder dabei und hat alles, was Hands-on-Tätigkeiten ist, übernommen. Cool ist auch die neue Webseite, blinklights.net, läuft auf Drupal jetzt. Als CMS? Ja, ich konnte endlich mal meine alte XSLT-Hackerei einschläfern. Das wollte ich nicht mehr pflegen, weil es war so eine statische Webseite, da konnte man keine dynamischen Features einbauen. Jetzt haben wir so Movie-Submissions, Login, Mitrechten und Pipapo und viele Leute können darauf rumarbeiten. Das ist viel besser. Drupal ist an sich ganz nett. Ich bin auch nicht so final überzeugt. Man muss schon ganz schön lange Wege gehen und man muss das gut kennen, um da wirklich eine tolle Webseite daraus zu machen. Aber da hatten wir hier den Caspar Metz, der hat uns da kräftig geholfen und hat das alles aufgesetzt, bis es so war, wie es jetzt ist. Das hat super funktioniert. Dann gibt es hier noch so einen anderen aus Toronto, den Robin Senior, der hier auch genannt ist. Der hat dann wiederum ein Interface für Processing gemacht, also eine Library geschrieben.
Genau, das habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Processing ist diese Software, mit der man mit ganz einfachen Java, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, tolle Animationen machen kann, oder?
Ja, fast. Das ist zwar in Java geschrieben, aber Processing ist eine eigene Programmiersprache. Die ist so ähnlich und ist aber sozusagen daraufhin optimiert, dass man eben Realtime-Animationen damit machen kann. Das ist so im Bereich der Medienkunst und den Kunsthochschulen sehr verbreitet. Processing läuft halt auf allen Plattformen und ist von daher sehr gut zu deployen. Ist auch Open Source, oder? Genau, ist auch Open Source. Und mit so ein bisschen von dem Java-Code, der hier sowieso geschrieben wurde, noch eine Library dafür gehackt, das als Processing-Library gepackt. Und schon hatten wir auch die Möglichkeit, direkt aus Processing heraus, Animationen für Blinkenlides zu machen. Da sind dann ja auch so einige Animationen drin gelandet, die das Tool benutzt haben.
Also ich habe hier, ich kenne so ein großartiges Blockslide 4.4, All Manner of Distractions, was mit diesen, der regelmäßig mal Animationen macht, die er mit diesem Processing gemacht hat, also wirklich unglaublich, was damit machbar ist. Das ist irgendwann, wenn ich eines Tages mal 20 Jahre Zeit habe, dann werde ich auch Processing lernen, so ein bisschen, und ein Ping-Pong-Spiel damit machen oder so was.
Ja, also das kann man durchaus empfehlen, also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr beliebt, es gibt da auch so einige Ressourcen, ich selber habe da jetzt nicht so viel mit gemacht, ich fand so das User-Interface immer so ein bisschen awkward, aber am Ende ist es halt einfach ein Coding-Environment, was eben vor allem für so Live-Grafik, sich verändernde interaktive Kunst super geeignet ist.
Und gut, dann noch ein paar andere Leute, die jetzt...
Und noch ein paar andere Leute, die halt Grafik gemacht haben, Björn hat wieder das Stereoscope-Paint beigetragen, viele Leute, die halt noch sonst irgendwas beigetragen haben, hier Martin und noch dieser Nat Quang, die haben vor allem dazu beigetragen, dass dieses 3D-Modell es wirklich aufs iPhone schafft. Wir mussten ja erst mal dieses ganze 3D-Modell bauen, von diesem Haus.
Das hattet ihr nicht. Also, ihr musstet ausdenken... Wie habt ihr das gemacht?
Ja, wir hatten so ein absurd großes und viel zu detailliertes Autocut-Modell, wo wirklich so jede Furche im Stein drin abgebildet war. Das war so dermaßen mega groß, dass verschiedene professionelle 3D-Firmen Schwierigkeiten hat, das in ihre Maya-Workstations oder sonst welche Sachen einzuladen. Das haben wir dann nur so zu 15 Prozent wiederverwendet bekommen, weil wir hatten irgendwie niemanden, der wirklich eine ordentliche Autocut-Installation hatte. Aber auf Basis dessen, was wir so konvertiert bekommen haben, wurde dann das Modell nochmal from the ground up neu gemacht. Auch im Hinblick darauf, dass es eben so wenig Polygone wie möglich hat, damit es eben auf dem iPhone noch performt, weil daher nur OpenGL ES vorhanden ist. Und von daher war halt Polygonreduktion da erstes Ziel.
Also selbst an der Stelle nochmal richtig aufwendig viel Arbeit gehabt.
Ja, also es war unfassbar, was das Team geleistet hat. Da kann ich echt nur den Hut ziehen. Und das macht einen doch schon auch sehr stolz, wenn man sieht, dass so viele Leute da so von begeistert sind, von dieser Idee, dass sie da einfach so viel Zeit und Energie reinstecken. Ja, weiß nicht, wie viel die von ihrer normalen Arbeit vernachlässigt haben, aber es war teilweise immens.
Also wie gesagt, auch ohne da gewesen zu sein, ich bin nach wie vor zu tief beeindruckt von dem ganzen Ding. Tu mir doch den Gefallen und umarm das Haus nochmal von mir. So, heute Abend vielleicht, wenn es dann wieder an ist. Na klar.
So, aber jetzt haben wir es vielleicht auch heute mal eine Sondersendung zu Blinkenleids, oder?
Genau, lassen wir doch von Tim weg, oder?
Ja, es ist ja nichts passiert und die neuen MacBooks lauern nächste Woche auf uns, aber wir können ja überlegen, ob wir nächste Woche gleich nochmal eine Sendung hinterher machen, weil wir sind sowieso ja irgendwie eine Woche im Verzug. Und vielleicht können wir uns ja nächste Woche nochmal zusammenfinden. Was meint ihr?
Wäre ich dabei? Das wäre doch eine tolle Sache, oder?
Ich dachte, du kommst erst Freitag wieder. Oder willst du dann nochmal remote machen?
Das können wir nochmal remote machen. Das klappt ja so schlecht nicht, oder? Aber vielleicht nochmal ein paar andere Sachen, um das Kanadathema hier nochmal zu beenden. Die Telekommunikations- und iPhone-Landschaft hier in Kanada. Das ist schon sehr interessant. Also unglaublich viele iPhones sehe ich hier. Also wohin ich gehe, in welchem Pub auch immer, überall packt irgendjemand ein iPhone aus. In der U-Bahn haben die Leute iPhones oder auch iPods. Ich habe heute auf dem Weg hierher in der U-Bahn überhaupt das erste Mal jemand mit einem anderen MP3-Player gesehen. Dann aber auch gleich zwei nebeneinander. Das eine war so ein komisches Teil, was irgendwie um den Hals hing. Wieder so einer von diesen hässlichen Blöcken. Neben so einem Japaner, der hörte tatsächlich Musik auf seiner Digitalkamera. Das war auch mal was Neues. Aber ansonsten scheint hier irgendwie alles ein iPod und ein iPhone zu sein. Es ist ein ziemlicher Erfolg hier in Kanada. Das kann man sicher sagen. Und das, obwohl die Telekommunikationslandschaft hier wirklich grausig ist. Es gibt ja hier nur einen einzigen GSM-Anbieter, der sich hinter zwei Marken versteckt und so ein bisschen die Illusion schürt, es gebe hier irgendeine Konkurrenz. Aber das ist Rogers, die ja sozusagen der offizielle Partner auch sind von Apple. Klar, weil das sind die Einzigen, die überhaupt ein GSM-Netzwerk haben. Es hätte sich hier überhaupt keine andere Firma angeboten. Die auch 3G machen, natürlich. Die hier noch unter der Marke Fido dasselbe verkaufen. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, Augenwischerei. Es handelt sich technisch um dasselbe Netz, faktisch um dieselbe Firma. Es ist nur einfach noch mal so ein zweites Branding mit leicht anderen Tarifen.
Und das kostet wahrscheinlich unverschämt viel.
Also die Telekommunikationspreise hier sind richtig frech. Also ich mag mich gar nicht mehr beklagen über irgendwelche Tarife in Deutschland, wenn man mal gesehen hat, was den Leuten hier aufgetischt wird. Vor allem, was für Ammenmärchen man erzählt bekommt. Wenn du hier einen Vertrag abschließt mit dem iPhone, dann musst du erstmal einen 3-Jahres-Vertrag abschließen.
Für ein iPhone, wenn du ein iPhone kaufen willst?
3 Jahre. Und die Kostenstruktur ist auch echt geil. Also ich kenne jetzt den iPhone-Tarif nicht so genau. Der ist vergleichsweise noch entspannt, weil wenn du hier normalerweise einen Tarif kaufst, dann hast du eine monatliche Gebühr, eine Einrichtungsgebühr. Dann musst du deine SIM-Karte kaufen, nochmal für 30 Dollar. Dann kommt zu dem eigentlichen monatlichen Tarif noch eine sogenannte System-Access-Fee dazu. Die offizielle Beschreibung dafür da ist, dass dein Anbieter dein Netz auch wartet und besser macht.
Oh, gut, super.
Man würde ja erwarten, dass das schon mit dem anderen Tarif irgendwie ist. Aber sie splitten das irgendwie nochmal so in 1000 Unterteile auf. Du musst sogar noch einen extra Tarif bezahlen, dafür, dass du die Emergency-Nummer benutzen darfst. Die 9-Eleven-Steuer ist irgendwie nochmal ein Dollar. Nicht, dass das jetzt viel ausmacht, aber auch das ist nochmal separat ausgewiesen.
Also das, was bei uns auch ohne SIM-Karte gehen muss, einfach damit das Telefon überhaupt erlaubt ist, kostet da nochmal extra?
Taucht zumindest als einzelner Posten auf. Das machen sie halt alles, um ihre eigentlichen Tarife, mit denen sie dann werben, natürlich niedrig zu halten. Sagen halt nur 30 Dollar im Monat.
Also so ein bisschen wie bei uns das Fliegen. Flughafengebühr und Coerosim-Steuer und so weiter.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Sie sagen halt, kostet 30 Dollar, aber dass deine SIM-Karte nochmal 30 Dollar, die System-Access-Feed 30 Dollar, die Emergency nochmal einen Dollar kostet und so weiter. Und das Ganze auch noch ein Netto-Preis ist, das ist halt plus Tax. Das sagt dir dann keiner. Also es ist alles vollkommen bekloppt. Ich habe hier mal versucht, so für einen Monat, es gibt auch Monatstarife, sodass du monatlich bezahlen kannst, aber ich kann dann irgendwie 0,50 Dollar, das passt mir dann irgendwie echt nicht wert.
Die Prepaid-Karte ist noch gar nicht erfunden.
Prepaid kriegst du ja irgendwie überhaupt nichts. Es heißt doch, es gibt Prepaid, aber nicht mit Daten, und ich war natürlich auf Datenschaf. Also das ist irgendwie alles total aulig.
Also mit anderen Worten, so schlimm geht es uns ja gar nicht in Deutschland.
Ja, so ist das. Dazu gibt es auch noch so andere Sachen. Wir hatten zum Beispiel hier unser WLAN auf dem Platz. Und ich habe das dann mal spaßweise auf Kanal 14 eingestellt. Und natürlich konnten sozusagen alle kanadischen iPhones das dann nicht empfangen. Weil die natürlich weniger WLAN-Kanäle in ihrer Firmware freigeschaltet haben.
Wieso natürlich? Wieso?
Weil das in Amerika nur bis zu Kanal 11 geht. Und 12, 13, 14 oder sogar nur bis 10, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ich glaube nur bis 10 sogar. Und was auch eine tolle Sache ist, Fidel hat sich hier einen iPod Touch gekauft, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ob der dann in Europa alle Frequenzen empfängt oder ob man das Ding noch mal als mit einer deutschen Firmware irgendwie flashen muss oder so. Vollkommen unklar. Das sagt dann natürlich auch keiner.
Das weiß wahrscheinlich auch keiner.
Ja, dann habe ich hier noch mein iPhone ein bisschen mal getestet, so mit GPS. Weil ich ja hier so ein bisschen, wenn man hier so an so einem Ort ist, wo man sich nicht so gut auskennt, da kriegt ja GPS auf einmal echt eine Bedeutung, obwohl es total scheiße ist, wenn du dann keine 3G-Datenverbindung hast.
Ich habe im Augenblick ein bisschen gerade das Problem, dass dein Skype irgendwie komplett, ich höre massenhaft Artifakte von dir durch, leider.
Das bist aber du.
Das bin ich?
Ich höre dich nämlich ganz schlecht, ja.
Ja, ich glaube auch, du bist das Problem.
Weil Tim höre ich prima und dich nicht.
Ich mache ja eigentlich gerade gar nichts übers Internet, das muss mal ein DSL-Anschluss sein.
Tja, bei wem bist du denn?
Ah, ich bin über einen falschen Hotspot drinne. Blöd. Jetzt hätte ich fast fuck gesagt, oder shit.
Transmission ausmachen.
Nee, nee, ich habe hier nichts am laufen. Ich bin hier einfach über, ich habe hier zwei Hotspots in meiner Wohnung.
Oder Apple schiebt gerade neue Updates raus für Unterstützung für die neuen Fernseher.
Ist wahrscheinlich so ein Snort. Wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen über das iPhone reden?
Wir können noch ein bisschen über das iPhone reden. Aber...
Ich will kurz ablästern. Und zwar, ich habe jetzt hier iPhone Development Access. Und das ist gar nicht mal mein eigenes, sondern über eine Firma. Und da wollte ich letztens diese Ad-Hoc-Installation machen. Da braucht man halt diese ID des Telefons. Und da muss man die irgendwie bei Apple in so einem Portal irgendwie eingeben. Und dann erstellt man sich so ein Provision. Und dann muss man der Person das Programm und dieses Provision-Profile irgendwie geben. Und damit wir es richtig testen können, haben wir jemanden genommen, dessen Rechner noch total jungfräulich ist, ohne schon irgendwie Xcode drauf zu haben oder irgendwie anders. Und dann habe ich mir die ID durchsagen lassen. Und habe die halt eingetippt. Oder besser gesagt, der andere hatte die eingetippt. Und der hatte die aber mit Großbuchstaben eingetippt. Das sind immer so Zahlen und Buchstaben. Und die Buchstaben hat dann groß eingetippt. Das haben wir bei Apple ins Portal eingegeben. Und wollten ihm dann das Programm zukommen lassen. Und da kamen immer nur so Versionen, die würde irgendwie nicht gehen. Und wir haben irgendwie drei Stunden gebraucht, bis wir gemerkt haben, dass die bei Apple wirklich case sensitive testen, was gerade bei Apple ja total unüblich ist. Und jetzt haben wir zwei Devices, einmal klein geschrieben und einmal groß geschrieben, bei Apple registriert. Und man kann auch gar keine Devices löschen. Wenn es einmal drin ist, ist es drin. Kriegst es nicht mehr raus. Total schlecht.
Ich dachte, das wäre auch ein Hex-String gewesen.
Da möchte man ja gar nicht meinen, dass da groß Dachten war ja auch, aber nee, nee. Die checken ja case sensitive. Ich meine, die könnten das einfach ändern bei Apple, indem sie einfach alle ID's schnell mal umkoden oder den Check irgendwie ändern. Also müsste man ja gar nichts weiter machen, aber das fand ich schon ganz schön...
Das heißt, sie interpretieren das als String und nicht als Hex-Zahl.
Sieht so aussichtlich.
Oder rechnet falsch um. Wahrscheinlich mit einer Subtraktion einfach.
Ansonsten haben die da wirklich alles durchsigniert mit Zerts und so weiter. Also deren DRM-System ist wirklich ganz schön... Also kryptisch weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber vom Ansatz her erstmal wasserdicht. Was soll ich sagen?
Jetzt hast du es gesagt. Zwei Mal. Ja, die Diskussion nehmen wir jetzt nicht wieder auf.
Das wär heute zu einfach für uns.
Ja, ansonsten hoffe ich ja, dass wir nicht zurückkommen, dass Deutschland noch steht und nicht gerade in einer Weltwirtschaftsrezession zugrunde gegangen ist. Offensichtlich, BlinkLights hat ja immer so Krisen. Also immer wenn wir so BlinkLights machen, dann passiert immer irgendwas ganz Schlimmes.
Ich dachte, ich hatte heute die Theorie, seitdem die CSU in Bayern nicht mehr die absolute Mehrheit hat, herrscht eine Weltfinanzkrise.
Nee, das liegt an uns. Das erste Mal, als wir BlinkLights gestartet haben, da gab es gleich 9-11 und so. Beim zweiten Mal in Paris wurde der Bürgermeister fast getötet von so Messerattentätern.
Der Pariser?
Diesmal gibt es Weltwirtschaftskrise.
Und jetzt ist irgendwie Weltwirtschaftskrise.
Gut, dass wir das alles noch alle paar Jahre machen.
Wir dürfen kein weiteres Projekt mehr machen.
Nein, wir sollten uns dafür bezahlen lassen, dass wir kein weiteres Projekt mehr machen. Ich würde sagen, wir legen alle zusammen. Solange da noch keiner auf die Idee kommt, machen wir weiter. So ein bisschen wie mit dem Regengott im Anhalter. Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis, ihr erinnert euch?
Das war so ein Buch von Doug Adams. Ja, ich habe das gelesen, aber ich kann mich an den Regengott nicht erinnern.
Dieser Typ, ein Lastwagenfahrer, wo auch immer er ist, es regnet. Es regnet so viel, dass bei ihm regnet es einfach immer. Das heißt, er nimmt die Welt einfach nur noch über Regen wahr und hat auch den verschiedenen Regenformen schon 125 verschiedene Kategorien zugeordnet. Es ging dann so weit, dass bestimmte Gemeinden ihn dafür bezahlen, dass er da halt nicht hinkommt, weil es ja dann regnen würde.
Und bestimmte bezahlen ihn, damit er kommt, damit es regnet. Wahrscheinlich.
Davon war im Buch zumindest nicht die Rede.
Und er war Engländer, nehme ich an.
Davon ist auszugehen.
Na, da regnet es doch eh immer. Aber Jungs, jetzt kommen ja bald diese eventuell neuen Rechner. Wir wollten ja nicht so viel irgendwie drüber quatschen, weil es wird sich ja alles zeigen, weil die Gerüchteküche schlagen ja eh in alle Richtungen, dass man sowieso schon gar nichts mehr weiß. Aber trotzdem hätte ich ja doch gerne, dass jeder so seine Prognose abgibt.
Oh, okay, du meinst mal wieder so ein bisschen, mal beweisen, dass man kompetent ist und nicht immer nur dumm redet?
Beweisen, dass wir trotzdem gar keine Ahnung haben.
Also ich rechne, ich rechne damit, nach dem, was ich gehört habe, wir werden einfach ein neues Line-Up bekommen, wo unter Umständen diese Unterscheidung mit MacBook und Pro nicht mehr so deutlich ist, sondern es eigentlich nur noch so eine Linie von MacBooks ist, die sich im Wesentlichen durch ihre Größe unterscheiden, aber alle im einheitlichen Design daherkommen, sodass das R und das MacBook sozusagen die untere Einstiegsklasse sind, also das R von der Größe her und das kleinste MacBook, wie groß das auch mal sein mag, halt irgendwie billig ist, und die 15 Zoll und 17 Zoll dann im Wesentlichen im gleichen Design daherkommen, aber eben mehr Ports haben.
Also du meinst, das ist so eine Art, dass das...
Also ich erwarte nichts Revolutionäres, ich erwarte nur, dass die Dinger stabilere Gehäuse bekommen, weil sie irgendwie durchgehend Alurahmen sind und nicht mehr diese Plastikscheiße, wie derzeit beim Pro, dass die Pros eine ordentliche Tastatur kriegen wie die anderen.
Du meinst, die Auflagefläche für die Hände, die Plastikscheiße ist beim Pro?
Ja, also, wir haben da schon drüber geredet. Na, da wo du deine Hände drauflegst, neben dem Trackpad. Das ist Plastik.
Das ist mir nie aufgefallen.
Das fällt dir dann auf, wenn du so ein bisschen schweißigere Hände hast. Mir passiert das immer, dass wenn... Ich hatte ja so ein Powerbook und mein MacBook ist genauso. Wenn du da einfach häufig die Hände drauf hast und schwitzt, dann schwitzt du die Farbe raus.
Das ist weggekratzt, also...
Das wird so richtig chemisch rausgelöst, habe ich fast den Eindruck. Weil man kratzt ja nicht so viel, sondern es ist halt einfach nur permanent feucht. Und Schweiß kann schon recht aggressiv sein. Also es reicht auf jeden Fall, um diesen Plastik die Farbe zu entziehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall, das geht einfach nicht. Und ich hatte ja schon meine anderen Sachen immer beklagt. Man kommt halt an die Festplatte-Scheiße ran. Das müssen sie beheben. Ich denke, sie werden es irgendwie schaffen, dem großen MacBooks zumindest ein halbes Kilo zu entziehen. Und vielleicht dem MacBook auch. Das fände ich schon mal ganz gut. Dass sie so 500 Gramm leichter sind.
Das glaube ich ja nicht.
Warum nicht?
Wo sollen sie denn die wegnehmen?
Sollen sie sich was einfallen lassen?
Dünneres Alu. Weiß nicht, ich glaube, die sind schon ganz schön gestafft.
Keine Festplatte, irgendwie Flash reinbauen und...
Ja, mit Flash könnte eine Menge kommen.
Also als Angebot. Das Gehäuse einfach weniger Elektronik, kleineres Board, alles kleiner, alles leichter.
Es gibt ja immer noch die Umsatzwarnung im Haus, oder, für das vierte Quartal, ich weiß nicht, wie viel man auf die geben kann, aber dass aufgrund einer massiven Technologieumstellung die Gewinne einbrechen würden im vierten Quartal. Sie werden ja wohl kaum die Finanzkrise vorher gesagt haben.
Ja, ich hatte ja gesagt, das bezieht sich auf die iPods, damit habe ich nicht recht behalten. Könnte sein, dass sich das auf das MacBook bezieht, aber das Quartal ist ja eigentlich schon vorbei. Das Quartal ist vorbei? Der iPod Touch ist billiger geworden, oder?
Der iPod Touch ist ein bisschen billiger geworden, aber nicht wirklich billig.
Na, das Quartal ist eigentlich schon durch. Diese MacBooks werden es auf jeden Fall nicht mehr für dieses Quartal beitragen.
War das nicht angekündigt für das vierte Quartal, die Warnung?
Das vierte Quartal ist das dritte Kalender. Das ist das Business-Quartal. Das ist alles um ein Quartal nach vorne geschoben. Das ist jetzt eigentlich durch. Von daher kann das jetzt damit nichts mehr zu tun haben. Vielleicht hatte ich doch recht, und das bezieht sich auf den iPod Touch, der ist ja billiger geworden, dass sie da einfach nicht mehr mit der gleichen Marge arbeiten bei dem Teil, um einfach die Preise so niedrig zu halten, wie sie es haben. Hat sich jetzt bloß nicht so massiv für uns ausgewirkt.
Also ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die neuen, also es gibt ja diese Gerüchte um dieses iBreak Zeug, dass sozusagen Apple einen Prozess erfunden hätte, um aus einem Alublock heraus ein komplettes Gehäuse quasi mit Laser und Wasser zu frischen. Das ist Quatsch.
Das ist Quatsch?
Das halte ich für totalen Blödsinn. Es gibt so einen schönen Artikel bei Roughly Drafted, warum das totaler Quatsch ist, das wäre viel teurer und das würde auch nichts bringen. Das sind einfach so Sachen, die denken sich einfach irgendwelche Leute aus. Da müssen wir echt nicht drüber reden, das ist Quatsch.
Was haltet da von dem Fernsehgerücht? Dass Apple HDTVs irgendwie rausbringen will, die dann gleich deren Service benutzen und so? Mein Kumpel von mir vor ein paar Jahren schon, da meinte ich auch, Apple bringt doch keine Fernseh raus. Und wenn es jetzt wirklich stimmt, dann muss ich ihm ja recht geben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Apple Fernseher rausbringt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das kommt. Warum sollten sie? Apple probiert immer, die Produktpalette so klein wie möglich zu halten.
Also Fernseher direkt mit IP, vielleicht sogar mit Verträgen, mit den Kabelfirmen, da irgendwie das Programm zu streamen?
Apple wird kein Produkt rausbringen, was nicht in weitgehend unveränderter Version so weltweit zu betreiben ist. Und Fernseher ist schon so eine Technologie, die extrem lokal marktabhängig ist mit diesen ganzen unterschiedlichen Empfangsstandards.
Aber du brauchst immer noch einen klassischen Fernseher dran, fürchte ich für die Leute.
Aber der Internet-Fernseher ist Apple TV plus großes Bildschirm.
Vielleicht kommt jetzt der große Bildschirm mit dem Apple TV Integrated.
Warum sollten sie das machen? Das Ding ist so klein, steht da irgendwie net daneben. Ich halte das für Quatsch. Du wolltest ja wissen, was wir denken, was bei den MacBooks irgendwie kommt. Ich habe meine Hoffnung noch nicht ganz aufgegeben, dass die Geräte GPS kriegen. Ich habe in den letzten Tagen häufiger schon so Fälle gehabt, wo mir einfach GPS, bzw. generell Lokalisierung, Automatisch Lokalisierung... Nö, du bist hier in Toronto und suchst irgendwie nach einem Pizzaservice. Da musst du erstmal wissen, wo du überhaupt bist. Und wenn du irgendwie nicht in deiner eigenen Stadt bist, dann musst du erstmal rauskriegen, wo du bist. Und so wirstest du dann auch gleich, wo du bist. Und das kann einfach hilfreich sein.
Aber da gibt es jetzt für Firefox dieses Geode-Plugin von Mozilla, mit dem man immer seine Position ermitteln kann. Über Skyhook Wireless. Direkt aus der Seite heraus.
Das heißt Geode?
Ich glaube, das heißt Geode, ja. Ich suche nochmal einen Link dazu raus. Das wird in Firefox 3.1 eingebaut sein. Gibt es irgendwie seit drei Tagen. Funktioniert, funktioniert viel besser als die entsprechende Google-Ulisung. Google zeigt mit Mühe und Not an, wo man sich grob in einer Stadt aufhält. In welcher Stadt man sich aufhält.
Aber wir sind uns einig, dass wenn Apple das wirklich drin haben wollen würde, dass sie es dann gleich so machen wie bei iPhone. Dann würden sie es auch gleich ins Betriebssystem einbauen und nicht in Firefox. Also ist wie gesagt nur so eine Hoffnung. Ich sehe wenig, was dagegen spricht. Das mag Apple anders sehen. Aber ich finde, so ein GPS-Receiver gehört einfach in so einen Laptop rein. Genauso wie ein 3G-Slot. Also sie sollten einfach wie beim iPhone einen kleinen SIM-Karten-Slot an der Seite haben, wo du einfach eine SIM-Karte reinsteckst. Und dann hast du einfach da deinen Datentarif.
Das wäre wirklich mal was Fremdes.
Ja, das ist einfach total nötig. Man läuft mit diesem scheiß Laptop durch die Gegend und man hat einfach an manchen Stellen kein Internet. Warum?
Ich will nicht kein Internet haben.
Das haben ja teilweise schon 3G-Modems eingebaut. Warum eigentlich nicht Apple-Rechnungen?
Ja, und bei den niedrigen Preisen, die jetzt da weltweit gehandelt werden und die fallen am laufenden Meter. Warum nicht?
Ich hoffe, dass wir das endlich mal schaffen, den Helligkeitssensor nicht in einer Tastatur im Lautsprecher einzubauen, sondern zum Beispiel neben dem Mikro, damit man auch mal die Funktion nutzen kann zum automatischen Display-Abdins sinnvoll. Und das Mikro auch ein bisschen nach oben. Das liegt so auf dem MacBook Pro. Wenn man die Hände auf den Lautsprecher legt, dann dimmt das Display runter, weil es denkt, dass der Raum dunkel geworden wäre.
Nimm deine Hände vom Lautsprecher.
Das passiert mir nun mal manchmal beim Tippen, dass ich da die drauflege.
Das Mikro ist doch auch bei den Lautsprechern.
Ja, und da tritt man auch die ganze Zeit drauf rum. Das sollte oben bei der Kamera sein. Habe ich beim Mikro gesagt? Bei der Kamera soll das sein.
Die Kamera können sie weglassen, dann sollen sie das UMTS reinmachen.
Nein, Kamera soll drin bleiben, um Himmels willen. Ich möchte meine Kamera behalten. Kamera ist super. Kann man tolle Fotos mitmachen, kann man Videotelefonie mitmachen, kann man alles mitmachen. Kamera ist großartig.
Meine Prioritätenliste ist, die Dinger müssen leichter werden, die Dinger müssen stabiler werden, die Dinger müssen kälter werden.
Kälter?
Ach, kälter. Nicht so heiß werden, genau. Und dann sollten sie UMTS kriegen und sie sollten GPS kriegen. Und wenn davon irgendwie eine nennenswerte Prozentzahl erfüllt wird, dann wäre ich sogar bereit, mein schwarzes MacBook gegen so ein silbernes Teil wieder zu tauschen.
Was ist das Problem damit, wenn sie die Batterie nicht wechselbar machen?
Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass ich, glaube ich, in meinem MacBook meine Batterie, glaube ich, noch nie gewechselt habe, außer ich habe die nur rausgenommen, um an die Festplatte ranzukommen. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, hier jemals schon mal eine andere Batterie eingebaut zu haben.
Also es gibt bestimmt jetzt eine Menge Leute, die das natürlich voll oft machen, jetzt alle aufschreien werden. Aber ich denke mal, das wäre ein Weg, zum Beispiel um so ein Gehäuse stabiler einzukriegen, weil das Batteriefach macht es natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen anfälliger.
Ja, aber das muss auch gehen. Also kann mir jetzt keiner erzählen, dass es eine unmögliche Ingenieursleistung ist, eine Batterie so einzubauen, dass sie...
Na, ich denke schon.
Stabilität, naja, keine Ahnung.
Da kriegst du so ein Gehäuse stabiler hin, aber dann wird es ja auch schwerer.
Für mich persönlich wäre es nicht so sehr ein Problem, aber ich glaube, es wäre für viele Leute ein Problem. Weil mit einem Laptop willst du schon sicher Strom haben können und da ist dann so eine Ersatzbatterie schon ganz gut. Allein schon auch, um auf die Situation schnell reagieren zu können, wenn eine Batterie irgendwie nicht mehr performt.
Ja, aber um eine zum Auswechseln dabei zu haben... Ich wechsle die zwar auch nicht aus, aber ich musste schon mal eine einschicken an Apple. Ich finde es schon. Bei so einem Laptop würde ich ungern das Feature missen, auch wenn ich es vielleicht nicht jeden Tag brauche. Aber was ist jetzt bei den MacBooks? Haben die MacBooks mittlerweile eine LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung? Mal langsam, die kleinen?
Nein, die haben die noch nicht. Das wollte ich vorhin noch noch sagen. Die MacBooks werden das unter Garantie bekommen. Du meintest ja, wo sollen sie noch Gewicht sparen? Da können sie zum Beispiel Gewicht sparen.
Sind die MacBooks leichter geworden als die LEDs da gekommen sind?
Nee, aber grundsätzlich erlauben die einfach schon mal eine geringere Gehäusedeckeltiefe und alles, was weniger Volumen hat, erlaubt auch letzten Endes eine Gewichtseinsparung.
Und sie verbrauchen theoretisch ein bisschen weniger Strom als die klassischen. Und damit kann man eigentlich den Akku wieder ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Ich denke, die MacBooks werden im Wesentlichen die Geräte sein, die von diesem Modellwechsel profitieren.
Ja, das kommt halt wirklich ein Neues.
Höhere Auflösung des Bildschirms wäre auch nicht falsch.
Ja, die gleiche Option wie bei den 17 Zollern, auch für die 15 Zoller, dass man irgendwie bei 100 Dollar Aufpreis sagen kann, man will 1600 irgendwas haben anstatt 1440.
Das wäre aber was Schönes, wobei ich mit meinem Display eigentlich im Augenblick gerade ziemlich zufrieden bin persönlich, muss ich sagen.
Man ist nie zufrieden, Mann.
Ich bin gerade zufrieden mit meinem Display, was soll ich tun? Tut mir leid, ich bin überhaupt zufrieden mit meinem Display. Schlag's ein!
Meiner funktioniert leider auch super.
Und das, obwohl du ihn schon auf die Straße geschmissen hast, Menschenskinder.
Okay, Jungs, war das genug? Glaskugel?
Das war genug.
Und dann haben wir uns ja den Rest, wir können ja dann nächste Woche, nächste Woche Mittwoch uns wieder zusammenfinden.
Genau, dann machen wir die Glaskugelauflösung.
Und dann machen wir die Glaskugelauflösung und gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwie recht behalten haben oder nicht.
Genau, dann gibt es einen Tipp, was heute so die letzte Animation sein wird, die dann heute abläuft, heute Nacht? Habt ihr irgendwas Spezielles vorbereitet auf der Wand?
Interessanter Hinweis, habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken zumachen.
Ja, dann mach mal einen Countdown zum Abschluss oder sowas.
Ja, mal gucken.
Okay.
Ich denke mal drüber nach. Haben wir es? Wir haben es.
Wir haben es.
Dann sagen wir schönartig Tschüss. Tschüss an die Hörer. Das war übrigens MobileMacs, die Ausgabenummer. Die 14, oder?
Ne, wir haben schon die 13 hinaus.
Ich blicke da schon gar nicht mehr durch. Weil wir die 10 hatten.
Letztes Mal war die 13, jetzt die 14, danach die 15. Immer schön in der richtigen Reihenfolge bleiben. Und ja, nächstes Mal wissen wir dann auch gleich von Anfang an, welche Sendung es ist.
Und dann geht es auch wieder um Macs.
Und dann geht es auch wieder um Macs. Und nicht nur um Blinkenlites, genau. Okay, dann bis bald, tschüss!
Tschüss! Tschüss!